Hi everybody.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Both Brian and I have used them.
They're awesome.
People love them.
Great.
Don't say that Brian,
cause that's not true.
Are you allowed to suck on them and like is it poisonous?
Like is there any powder on it?
90% mineral oil out here.
So you could,
you could tell you eat it if you wanted to.
It's not recommended.
Now we met our friend Aubrey,
the artist formerly known as Chris through a,
the fleshlight who is now optimus prime.
And you said a recent experience?
Yeah,
we don't know if he's changed his name again.
Um,
it was Chris and then he had a crazy psychedelic experience and that made him
change his name to his middle name,
which was his grandfather's name.
So that's,
that's the,
that's it.
The genesis behind the Aubrey name.
Just for future reference,
what is your grandmother's name?
Bonnie.
She's the one here on the on the arm.
So you're bonding or lost.
So you put it,
you say it's real coffee Bonnie.
Right.
It's getting a little boy,
man try that domain.
Johnny got how many times you can only change your name once after that.
Like you can't keep fucking around,
right?
Yeah.
People are don't allow that.
Like they'll let you do it once.
Even once they're like what?
How old are you?
You know,
I mean I would have changed my name if I knew you could do prior to there was a
real practical element too cause I was actually born my father after I was named
after my father ceremoniously Michael,
so like the bank and all that shit.
They would call me Michael,
which was super annoying because I was Chris,
so I just decided drawing the line in the sand.
I'm choosing one,
my middle name Auburn.
But the spiritual thing actually led me to choose that one versus than just
changing my name officially.
You should never say the spiritual thing.
Like you should really be like super clear as to what the fuck you're talking
about.
Unless you already know because people could like,
take that out of quote.
Here's a recent quote by Aubrey Micro Margaret.
So the spiritual thing,
yeah.
Made me change and just,
sorry to go on so far,
the practice of the type of man you want running your business.
Well,
what he means by the spiritual thing.
And so life changing Iowasca experience,
they have it at pier one didn't get that block chain.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com oh and it makers of Alpha brain
and a Alpha brain,
my favorite,
uh,
nootropic supplement.
And Aubrey also makes that as well.
So that's crazy.
What a coincidence.
That doesn't even make sense.
This is a board meeting.
No commercial,
Bro.
You know how we do it.
Our commercials are fucking stupid,
but that's the only way to get through them.
I need more of that new alpha brain.
I don't have,
do you have any,
what would you,
why don't you explain now for brand new people since you're the,
you're the man behind the shed.
Explain it.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
what we were trying to do is create,
you know,
concentrated nutrients that would help many different types of
neurotransmitters.
Lift them all up without getting your too out of balance.
So we really focused on Acetylcholine,
a bumping up your acetylcholine levels with two Perseus Harada,
which is an Acetylcholine esterase inhibitor,
which helps prevent the breakdown of a acetylcholine and then boosting it up
with Alpha GPC,
a very potent bioavailable form of Coleen.
So that's going to raise your acetylcholine levels,
which is what accounts for sharpness,
acuity,
just kind of being on your game.
Um,
but some of the,
some of the downside of that is people can get a little hyper,
they can get a little manic.
So we put some anxiety,
lytic anti-stress herbs in there,
uh,
as well oat Straw and a few other things.
A gabba stimulating herbs as well.
And then combine that with a bunch of super strong antioxidants to kind of
eliminate that,
the clutter in your mind,
that kind of fog that you get when you're just having to deal with an oxidating
uh,
effects and um,
put it all together to make a,
what we call a balanced nootropics tropics here.
What's the deal with Gabba?
Cause I've seen arguments that Gaba is not,
it doesn't,
it's not bio available when you,
when you ingest it,
there's,
there's some research yeah.
Points to um,
nutritional Gabba not being able to effectively cross the blood brain barrier.
There's kind of studies on both side of the fence.
Some say that the blood brain barrier is leaky and so that using actual Gabba
even if it only comes in,
you know,
in small amounts is still effective.
Other people say no,
no,
it's a fucking,
it's the wall of China.
Nobody's getting,
you know,
nobody's getting through the blood brain barrier kind of arguments on both side.
I think in our future formulations were going to use for more [inaudible] in
conjunction as well,
which is definitely operates similarly on the Gaba mechanism and that way we'll
have,
uh,
have our bases covered.
But I'm part of the inclusion for Gaba is,
you know,
like all the things is,
we take it,
we give it to people to take on its own and um,
they felt that,
you know,
they notice the difference.
So
because there's a lot of anecdotal evidence that it works.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Do there's been studies,
even the,
that show that it works.
I don't,
you know,
I've,
I've really haven't experienced it.
I'm not sure.
You know,
I've never really just taken straight Gaba.
Yeah.
And tried to,
you know,
it's supposed to calm you down though.
That's the idea behind the important,
there are four important neurotransmitters,
so if it's not available that way,
how else,
how can people get it?
Well,
I'll,
theologian operates
pretty closely with that mechanism,
kind of like Al tyrosines operates on the,
on the l Dopa mechanism and some other things that we were using,
um,
as well.
Uh,
it's hard to get,
I mean the pharmaceuticals have done actually a very good job with the Gaba
formula.
They created something called Gabapentin and that,
um,
and that definitely by changing it,
that helps it cross the blood brain barrier.
But it's a trickier one as far as nutrition.
But I think the combination of Lte and nene and nutritional Gabba a is going to
be,
is going to be the best bet and I think we're going to have a even better
results than we currently have.
What do you say to people that are worried about this shit?
People that go,
well,
what are you doing man?
You're taking these weird nutrients and they're,
they're,
they're changing your,
your brain levels like,
but what are you doing?
Well,
you know,
it can be dangerous.
Yeah,
well all food is changing about your body.
You know,
every type of food you eat,
if you're having a greasy hamburger that's causing a certain effect,
does it,
what this is doing is basically concentrating really hard to get nutrients that
if you were following a special diet,
you know,
you could try and target and try and go after,
but we can't do it.
It's just doesn't make sense.
So you know,
by doing this we're giving ourselves an advantage.
It's like putting extra tools in your kit.
You know,
if you want to really be sharp and heightened these levels.
Yeah,
you could go out and find different things,
tons of things with natural levels of Coleen in it,
you know,
hit some less than like a madman and do a bunch of things like that.
Or you know,
because of our busy lives,
because we have other shit to do than go out and pound a bunch of less than,
you know,
we put these together in a nutritional supplement.
So it's just another tool in your kit.
Now you want a sick workout.
We have a formula for that.
You want to get it,
you know,
get your brain on it.
We got something there for that.
It's just extra tools in your toolkit that you can use and and go to whenever
you need to.
That's Alpha brain advertisement ever.
I always thought Gabba was that big green monster with the long arms that Gabba
Gabba Yo Gabba Gabba Gabba oh,
it's name is Yo Gabba.
Gabba yeah,
I thought that whole time that really up Gabba Gabba Gabba has a hit song called
don't bite your friends.
Yeah.
That's like one of those things where I've heard it.
I've heard Yo Gabba Gabba but I never really knew what it was.
It's this right here.
See Picture,
I think.
Oh Wow.
See,
I always thought that was gal.
That's weird.
I thought it.
I thought Alpha brain had that in it.
It's weird now.
Suddenly cut little pieces of it.
Reach you in the culture again or heard the name somehow over and over again.
It gets a kid show,
right?
It's awesome kid show.
Isn't that an adventure time?
My two favorite things.
Seriously.
All right.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t.
N,
a.
Checkout all the different supplements.
Where's I'm shroom tech sport from tech,
immune,
new mood,
all cool stuff,
all explained in depth and if you enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 10% off.
All right?
Actually right now to,
we want people to try these four minutes so every 30 count is 35% off.
If you just get the 35 count,
30 count bottle,
you sound like a salesman [inaudible] percent off,
but it's a good deal.
We just want you to try.
These are actually cool tools and we should also tell people that the first
three 30 pills we offer a 100% money back guarantee and the idea behind it,
and one of the cool things about doing business with you and knowing you as a
human being is that we're way more concerned with making sure that no one ever
feels ripped off than we are with making money.
It's the number one thing,
so we couldn't make it any easier.
Try it.
If you don't like it,
you your money back.
You know you have to return the pills.
He's just,
that's it.
Just let us know.
We'll give you your money back.
Yeah.
We just,
we just try to do the right thing and we're doing and,
and sone things that we actually take and believe in.
All right.
Halacha boy.
Yeah,
I'm Marcus is in the House,
Ladies and gentlemen.
We're going to experience,
try my day job.
You block gas by night.
All Day.
We're going deep kids deep to the dark jungles of Costa Rica deep.
Ooh,
you were in Costa Rica.
You were in Costa Rica.
You just returned.
Yeah.
And you had,
uh,
you went to an Ibogaine retreat.
If you don't know what I began is I began,
it's the stuff that hunter s Thompson accused a,
one of the guys who's running for president of being on,
and I was like in 1970 or whatever the hell it was to governor,
I believe it was McGovern or was he former governor?
I don't remember.
But if you watch the movie Gonzo,
uh,
the life and work of a hunter s Thompson,
they go into detail about how he just started saying that this guy was,
uh,
taken Ibogaine and that he was brilliant bringing in a Brazilian doctor.
He's just made up this shit and put it in the rolling stone and fucking people
were believing it.
And so everybody would go,
I think it's Ed Muskie.
I think that's the guy's name.
And everybody would go and watch this guy,
uh,
have speeches.
And he was having psychological meltdowns because hunter kept accusing him of
being on Ibogaine.
Yeah.
And so he would have,
there was this really crazy rambling speeches,
these campaign speeches where it's clearly a man who's just been deeply affected
by this fucked up thing that's happened to them.
Some guys just accused him of being on like some crazy psychedelic drug and the
guy just,
you know,
the pressure of the campaign and all that just crushed him.
It could just crush them.
But I began was the shit that was,
that was what a hundred shows that would be a very difficult drug to function
on.
I mean,
it is a challenge to lie on your back,
let alone give a speech.
Let's just put it that way.
What is the idea behind it?
It's,
it's been used in other cultures for eons.
Right.
So the origin of it,
they found a,
there's a legend surrounding,
you know,
uh,
a porcupine that found it was knowing on a tree and then the shaman,
you know,
came and brought it home to his wife to cook and the wife ate the porcupine and
just started tripping out and have this intense visions and encounters with
deities and understanding,
you know,
truth about things in a way that was never possible.
And the Shaman goes back to his wife.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
what's going on here?
And uh,
and then so you know,
they look back where they trapped the porcupine and was eating the bark of this
particular tree.
And the tree was the Boga tree,
which grows in a gap bone in Africa.
And so the Shaman took it,
got it directly from the source and started using the medicine and the it Bo got
booty tradition was born,
which is where the main shamonic tradition is.
And part of the shamanic tradition that I went to go see down in Costa Rica,
I went to see a gentleman who was a 10th generation.
We t Sharman straight out of Gabon.
So,
uh,
that's where it was initially founded.
And then it's got,
it gets a lot more press actually for,
it's,
um,
kind of drug rehab use.
There's a lot of,
for rehabilitation
for like heroin addicts and a in different people like that.
And that's,
they generally isolate the alkaloid ibogaine out of the Iboga root when they do
that.
So it's not quite the same as what we did.
We did a partial extraction,
so it was like half a bowl game,
but still had a lot of the full alkaloids of the,
uh,
of the,
of group.
But the clinics,
they just focus on the Ibogaine and have an amazingly high a success rate with
detox situations.
And I actually saw a gentleman down there at the Boga house where I went,
who showed up addicted to heroin and then just had a harrowing brutal like three
and a half day at bogus session and came out and he was on top of the world.
I mean really,
you know,
obviously the mold is what is the condo?
It's actually a,
it's a,
it's a bark.
Yeah.
But what is the actual,
you know,
ingredients are that the medicine side of that's making it?
Yeah,
it's an alkaloid actually.
So it's the Ibogaine alkaloid is the main alkaloid and then alkaloid is found in
the bark and in the roots of this particular tree that has this weird pepper
shaped fruit grows on it.
So what does it do with you?
Yeah,
well it's um,
you know,
the,
the interesting thing about a boga that separates it from everything else,
and I'll tell my full experience as well,
but um,
Thea Boga Schamens in the way they talk about it is completely different than
the Iowasca Shama I WASC a Shaman's talk about going farther.
Everything is about exploring other dimensions,
going beyond and bringing back information from those dimensions.
And the Bui Schamens they talk about going deeper,
like going farther inside yourself because inside of you is a soul that has
access to infinite knowledge.
So you can actually go inside yourself and find out the truth to virtually
anything without having to go outside.
So it's a whole different kind of paradigm has holy Shit.
And you know,
I really,
I mean as we'll get into my story,
the lucidity on a bogus,
unreal like nothing you've ever experienced.
It's almost like Iowasca when you're going farther and trying to pee,
you know,
trying to get information from these other dimensions.
There's a translation issue.
So sometimes it smashes against your perception and all you see are webs and
colors and figures and spirit teachers and weird shit cause you can understand
the information from beyond.
But at Boga it's like yourself talking to you.
It's like the best version of you just telling you what the fuck is up.
And you're like,
there's like no translation issue,
inner voice.
It's like that.
But it's like a,
it's like the ruthless inner voice of truth that you just can't fudge with it.
You can,
I mean,
there's no even arguing,
like there's some things that are uncomfortable to think about.
Like you don't want to look at them and it'll just be like,
stop,
stop bullshitting.
You know?
It's just ruthless.
I mean,
it's been compared to dealing with your stern father.
Well,
you know,
I mean that's not a paradigm that I use because that wasn't just how I grew up.
But I think for a lot of people,
you know,
that kind of voice of res w reason that's just,
not letting you slide and not letting you slack on anything comes in.
And that's really what you experience on the,
uh,
on the Boga.
Scared.
I'm scared.
Just listen to bark now.
Or are you like all different kinds of bars is a brutal experience.
Like I wast guts,
pageantry.
It's ceremony.
You get a flush.
Yeah,
you get a little nauseous.
It's fun.
It bogus.
Fucking intense.
Like is there anything else now?
They mix it with anything else?
We did fun.
It is not,
I mean,
it is a brutal,
harrowing experience.
Like did you do it again or would you be scared of,
yeah,
I would do it again,
but whoa.
It's only because of the amazing gains that you get.
I mean it's,
it's a ridiculously brutal experience.
And I'll,
I mean I guess I might as well just kind of get you guys into the story to tell
about all the physical,
a downside of it.
But it's rough.
I mean,
you're nauseous as fuck.
You're dizzy,
you know,
you can't walk,
you can't hardly drink water for,
you know,
24 hours.
You're on it forever.
You know,
it is not comfortable and not fun.
And it's like,
it's intense.
But that access to truth,
you know,
if you're trying to figure something out unparalleled,
that's like going on the biggest roller coaster.
I know things I [inaudible] good.
So
sounds like you lived the perfect life so that you never have to go through that
too.
Hey,
I have to die one.
Be the nicest person you could ever be in every possible situation.
Always do the right thing.
So you never have to take your boat.
And that's kind of,
you know,
there's funny,
the Shaman,
Shawn's very,
he's very kind of straightforward and he talks to you like a normal,
like most of these good shamans do.
They're not like pseudo spiritual.
They're not trying to create an aura of mysticism.
They're joking with you more than anybody.
They're lighthearted.
So he's joking around and he was talking about the guy who was detoxing from
heroin.
He's like,
I gave him enough that he will never want to do heroin again cause he's never
going to want to go through this shit.
And that's part of it.
I mean,
it's such a savage process that when they get out,
they're like not only have they learned things from the Voice of truth,
learn why they were doing it,
learn why they shouldn't do it,
and learn what it's doing in their body.
They just don't want to go have to see this dude again.
Who's going to just put them through the gauntlet.
Oh my God.
So it lasts 24 hours at least.
Geez.
There was people there who were up for three days.
So very similar to pod.
It will like the same kind of,
it's not similar to fucking anything.
Do I just care?
It's,
it was,
it was unreal.
So,
so I'll,
I'll tell you how it kind of goes about.
We go fly in the library.
I get picked up Liberia,
Liberia,
Costa Rica.
Yeah.
The northern airport.
Nice little like Africa.
Yeah,
it does.
It does.
Um,
get picked up,
get set in,
got a beautiful place like a ton of acres,
fruit trees,
coconuts.
You can cut off and drink the coconut water straight out of the coconut or
Poland fruit out of there.
It's like really nice set up,
you know,
and,
and find lodgings there's like a,
a lodging place for the people who were getting treated and going through the
ceremonies.
And then there's the,
in his house with his wife and his little baby are great.
And so,
uh,
we get in,
um,
first day we have our,
we just get a climatize and then we do what's called a spiritual shower,
which is kind of very similar across most mnemonic traditions.
It's kind of preparing you for that.
So we go to the Stream,
um,
did a ceremony where we put some intention into some leaves and let them kind of
flow through the river.
And I was impressed with the sham and then he did it with a lot of earnesty and
it felt just very,
very honest,
you know,
about what he was doing and just kind of preparing you,
um,
traditionally for what you're about to go through.
And then that night,
around seven 30,
we sit around there and we're in a little circle and uh,
he starts talking and he starts talking,
you know,
just generally about basically faith based experience and experience based
spirituality and just kind of railing against people who just believe things on
faith.
He says,
you know,
in our culture,
if we can't share that experience of multiple people can't get it.
It's bullshit.
You know?
And he was like pointing,
he was talking about astrology.
It's like spam.
People want to tell me that that star is going to make me feel a certain way.
Okay.
You know,
I'll go find out.
I'll go check,
I'll go see if that star doesn't give me anything.
Well,
I'm not going to believe it.
You know,
it's,
it's not,
it's not truth for me,
you know,
and that they have this very much kind of like a show me a kind of philosophy on
their spirituality,
which is very similar to what I encountered encountered in Peru as well when
they were talking,
you know,
very esoteric stuff about the weed or coach and about the soul leaving the body
and was like,
how do you know,
like,
oh,
we see it stupid,
you know,
like we see that happen and it's repeatable,
at least to them.
It's repeatable,
are not saying is native to a gap bone in Africa.
So,
and it's actually,
it's legal in,
in Costa Rica and a lot of South American countries,
legal in the UK as well actually.
Um,
but,
um,
but it comes out of Africa,
so they just ship it over and he prepares it in the same way.
They ship them the whole bark and he,
uh,
he does the preparations on it.
So we're going in this little speech and he gives us one pill and you know,
looks like about a gram and a half capital kind of a horse capsule with a brown
kind of powder in it.
And then he keeps talking and you know,
kind of talking in is in about different things.
Just pretty normal things.
He was talking about how hope is a prison,
you know,
hope traps people as much as fear because people sit around hoping for
something,
Oh,
I hope this is going to happen.
You know,
instead of just going out and doing it and they have a real kind of tradition
where it's like,
if you want something,
you know,
you manifest it,
you believe in it,
you've set your intent and you go fucking get it.
Like don't sit around hoping for something cool to happen.
Like that's just not the way they work.
So he was,
it was some cool stuff that he's talking about it,
what's going on for a while.
Then he passed around another pill and he didn't know how much he was going to
give us.
He kind of feels it out.
Uh,
as you go and kind of assess as you and what you need.
So we take a another horse pill and it's partially a straw extracted,
Ibogaine mixed with the Iboga root.
So getting some combination of both.
He also gives some people spoonfuls of the actual bark,
but that's more for a physical detox,
I think under what he was talking about.
It makes you even more nauseous,
which more nauseous.
I can't even fucking imagine how terrible that is.
So is there,
anyway,
so we start to,
it's been about an hour,
like a good hour a half since we took it.
And I'm still not feeling anything and I'm starting to get a little cocky and
I'm thinking,
Oh man,
you know,
maybe I'm just so experienced,
maybe this is not gonna not gonna hit me.
You know,
when to start worrying that maybe he didn't give me too.
You didn't give me enough.
So I'm thinking all that,
but,
and then,
you know,
as they're doing it with my fiance and uh,
and she started to drop,
like she started to feel it,
right?
So she moves over to the bed and she's feeling a lot of things.
She's certainly not as experienced as me.
So she started to feel a lot of weird things and I'm like,
I'm really not feeling it.
You know,
I'm not not quite there yet.
And the Shamina one of the traditions in,
in the it bogus ceremonies is you talk to different people,
you talk to get direct access to talk to their souls.
They say so whether they're alive or dead,
you just have conversations with them.
And that's like one of the main staples of the tradition of their spirituality.
So he's still whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What?
Yeah.
So that's so you,
whether they're alive or dead,
you're talking to them.
Yeah.
It's almost like you're talking to them.
This is what they believe.
Now,
now I'm gonna,
I'm gonna put a disclaimer out there,
but in the state you felt this as well.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you,
I'll tell you how it,
how it goes a little later.
Cause at this point I didn't feel anything right.
So he was trying to ask and you should prepare these questions.
It's different from another ceremony to other ceremonies.
You prepare your intent,
what you want to get out of it pretty much across the board,
whether it's mushrooms,
Payoti,
Iowasca set your intent and this you do it even more focused and you actually
write questions down and questions you want to get answered.
You know,
of some people calling,
asking Doctor Boga,
you know,
cause the Boga will tell you the answer.
So he actually has you write the questions.
So he starts trying to ask Kaitlyn and these,
these questions and uh,
and she's,
you know,
she's having a tough time.
So she says,
so he goes over to me and he's like,
well,
why don't you,
why don't you respond for Kaitlin?
You know,
like have the conversation with her.
And I'm like,
ah,
I'm just not feeling it.
She's like,
doesn't matter.
It's not about the medicine.
Like,
you know,
you know what her soul would say,
like,
you know how to answer these questions.
And I was like,
ah,
I can't see it.
And he kept trying to do these visualization things and I kind of like half
imagined it,
half kind of faked it just to get through.
And I was,
I guess the question I was answering better than I thought I would,
but so he goes through this whole thing and then you know,
and then he kind of finishes with that and he smiles and I guess he had gotten
me to the point that he wanted,
which was that to realize that I didn't need to take the medicine to have access
to the truth.
And I think that's one of the good things about it Boga is you learn,
it's easier to take what you learned there and apply it elsewhere.
So then,
but pretty much as soon as he hit,
he was finished talking.
I started to feel like I'd walked into a high voltage shed and it was like an
intense hot buzzing around my whole body.
And my heart was thumping like crazy and I was like,
Holy Shit,
am I nervous?
Like am I freaking out here?
Like am I panicking,
panic attack and my heart's just boom,
boom,
boom.
I'm like thumping in my chest and he starts playing this music that's Brian's
playing right now and I'm just hammered in my chest and in the buzzing gets
crazy intense like around me,
like zero.
Like literally like I was in a high voltage tech and things start to get
nauseous.
I start to get dizzy and it feels at some point I hear,
I hear my fiance go,
I feel like I'm spinning in this Shannon.
Just very matter of fact that scopes make it stop.
And then so when I was spinning I was just like make it stop.
Okay.
And you could,
you had that kind of control to do it,
but it was miserably uncomfortable and my eyes started to get real fucked up.
So we had blindfolds and we lay down and then,
you know,
just kind of dealing with this bad experience so far as far as what I'm feeling
when I'm going through.
And then all of a sudden things start to crystallize a little bit more.
And I start to see this like almost like the only thing I can talk about it
being similar to is like the cursor on a Google search.
Like I could literally point to anything I wanted to go and any question that I
had and find answers and access that would come to me and usually in words,
but sometimes in pictures when I needed pictures.
So then I was,
I had full kind of control over this experience.
Yeah,
it was nuts.
Like,
and so there for air,
from there I start going through my questions and I had about 10 questions and I
start analyzing different things.
So my first question was very personal.
It was about what,
you know,
my own demons,
my own limitations,
things that were holding me back.
And it gave this very kind of like in depth dissertation about the different
aspects of myself.
So there was one aspect,
which was kind of my soul aspect,
you could call it,
if you will,
and that some people have called it your God's self,
but that's your ideal self,
that's your actualized being.
That's your soul.
You know,
the,
the best part of yourself,
but then there was the mind and the mind does all kinds of things for survival
that end up sabotaging what you're really want to do there.
What you know,
what Pressfield would call resistance,
you know,
all of these different games that your mind will play when it's running the ship
and it when it's at the helm that are going to sabotage what you're trying to
get out of life and your true happiness.
For me it was,
you know,
certain fears,
certain fears of um,
you know,
bad things happening,
fear I might get sick or fear,
I might,
you know,
something bad might happen or worries about this worries about future events
that didn't need to happen.
All of these worries and fears,
which are part of some stupid survival mechanism and you know,
these doubts that my mind had created and I realized that that wasn't really me.
That was just some apparition of my mind.
And so I ended up naming that part of myself,
you know,
the dominion of name.
I named it mind boy.
And that's,
that was an important,
crucial lesson there for me is that not always are you acting under your best,
truest being.
You know,
sometimes you got this juvenile little stupid kid who's trying to fuck up,
you know,
your happiness and sabotaging you and that's your mind.
And so unique,
just being a,
being able to recognize that,
you know,
was able to kind of put that in its place and uh,
and make a huge difference.
And then of course,
the third component is,
you know,
the physical being,
your body,
the primate part of yourself.
And um,
you know,
that's,
um,
I think maybe in some illusion,
uh,
to what to being called clay before I had the image that it was mud,
you know?
And so I called that mud body.
And what is mud body like?
My body likes to fight,
my body likes to fuck,
mud,
body likes to eat,
you know,
he just likes the physical parts of things.
And that's the very animal side of us.
And,
and that's,
you know,
that's an important side.
I mean,
that's part of the joy and the magic of being alive.
But you can't get run by that shit either.
You know,
you can't be just on some obsession to cram as much pleasure into every orifice
you can,
either food through your mouth and coke in your nose and Dicks in your ass.
I don't know,
whatever,
whatever.
You know,
whatever mud body wants,
he can't just be a slave to that either.
And really the key is to try and let that eternal,
that best part of yourself run the show as much as possible.
So that right there,
that lesson,
just being able to kind of visualize that,
you know,
it was so simple,
but it's an experience that I'll always remember.
Like even driving around,
you know,
concerned about some of them that I'll have a worry,
I'll have a fear and I'm like,
ah,
you know,
shut the fuck up mind boy you're,
you're,
you're out to get out of here.
Like I don't need you right now.
And you'll be able to kind of identify what's not your best interest.
And just dispatch of it.
Right.
Do you have any desire to do I would gain of course tonight,
you know,
I think I'll,
I'm happy not feeling any of this.
I think that's feels like,
I think that feels like death to me.
That's not,
that doesn't seem happy.
Like I want to do stuff that like,
like makes me happy and then he's like,
shrooms makes me happy.
Molly makes me happy.
Yeah,
that's about it.
We mixed.
We have,
I think,
you know,
depending on what and what
your goals are,
but I think that uh,
all the various psychedelic experiences can offer unique perspectives on life,
you know?
But I think for sure a little different taste of each one of them is going to
give you a different sort of a thing.
There are different,
you might,
different tools,
you would hate it,
but I bet when it was over you'd be [inaudible].
No,
it does not sound fun.
So fun.
It does,
it gets the whole experience as a total.
I mean it has certainly its positives and its negatives.
But this,
this,
you know,
so you have immense physical discomfort,
but your mind is just on fire.
I mean,
you're thinking things really perfectly clearly.
You've never eaten pot and gone into an isolation tank.
Have you?
I,
I did.
Actually.
I don't have a good,
I don't have a good relation.
That's the only time I've done the isolation tank,
unfortunately.
But I don't have a good relationship with,
with pot like it especially eating it.
No,
no.
It's just not something that I can deal.
It gives me a little,
it gets me both oddly and paradoxically sleepy and anxious at the same time when
I eat it.
Although when I,
when I smoke it,
I feel either sometimes goofy,
but sometimes awesome and lucid.
So it's that kind of would,
depending on what kind of part you're getting to and I have no fucking clue.
Yeah.
So that's the issue.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
We've,
we've discussed ad nauseum with people because most people in the country that
don't have a medical marijuana program don't know that there's two different
types of pot.
Yeah.
Indicating Sativa Shit.
Nowadays.
Most kids that listen to this show know that everybody,
exactly.
Yeah.
I'm telling people in cases like your dad's listening for the first time.
My Dad even knows that your dad's a scientist.
My mom wants to,
we're wants to smoke weed I think,
I think and stuff like that because every time she's been bringing it up in such
a positive light lately.
And then I talked to somebody else's,
uh,
who I know their mom,
their Franks from Ohio and they want,
her mom wants to smoke weed right now.
I don't want to say here.
And so it's kind of weird.
And my mom's friends with that person.
Wow.
So,
well,
you know what Pat Robertson just turned the corner on everybody.
Yeah.
Pat Robertson just said that we should be illegal.
Fucking Robertson.
Who thinks,
you know,
Satan is alive and well living in Afghanistan.
Got To get people over this fear.
It's such bullshit.
I mean these are valuable fucking tools.
Like you got it.
And we got to know about him first of all.
You know,
I mean,
it's one thing for me to take it,
but what if we had geniuses taking obligate,
you know,
that's when that's what you need.
You need like find these fucking people who are on the cusp of brilliance and
give them access to these tools and who knows what they'll find.
Actually,
I just recently learned that Francis Crick,
the guy who first perceived the DNA helix,
the double helix molecule,
admitted before he died,
that he perceived the DNA double helix while on acid.
Yeah.
But it's totally like this.
There's no evidence that,
you know what I mean?
Someone said it.
So instead of completely anecdotal,
maybe,
you know,
but it makes sense.
Well,
did,
it is true though,
the Francis Crick,
it was a regular user of Lsd then.
I think that has been documented.
There's a lot of those guys.
I mean,
why wouldn't you be when you,
back in the day when no one really knew what the fuck was going on and none of
the things,
none of these things would become illegal yet.
Yeah.
And one guy would have amazing results and he'd be recognized as a,
you know,
a brilliant guy by his peers.
So they'd be like,
well,
what the fuck are you doing?
Let's,
let's try this.
What's happening here?
Yeah,
I've had a lot of them did it.
It's been,
it's been around.
I actually finished Graham Hancock's book supernatural,
which is amazing,
isn't it?
Awesome book.
Yeah.
I mean,
and he goes through that whole story of so many different cultures back from the
Paleolithic cave drawings too.
You know,
the,
the temple of elusive and ancient Greece
and Rome and where they're actually,
he thinks eating Ercot,
which is that a,
a some mix of ergot fungus,
which has lysergic acid in it.
So I think it is the hero's journey,
you know,
that's what I think these psychedelic trips on it.
I know people say,
that sounds grandiose.
It sounds ridiculous.
But when you,
when you take a psychedelic,
there's a reason why it's called a trip.
It's not an ordeal.
It's a trip.
You're going,
so you're going on a fucking hero's journey.
You're going to be a hero of your own life to sort of reconstruct your own life
and get a chance at at starting in a new gonna reset button.
Get a kind of perspective enhancement where got you realize the terrible
patterns even existing under and you don't have to do them anymore.
Let's get through this.
But yes,
a Horowitz ordeal.
But every warrior must go through horrid battles.
Yeah,
that's it.
I mean we don't have this place.
I don't have the external fights that we used to.
I mean some people are yet UFC fighters,
they don't last.
But really those,
those kind of external manifestations of testing what you have in a life or
death situation and we don't have it,
but where are we can find that still is going deep,
challenging,
you know,
facing your fears about death and coming out the other side.
I mean that,
that's it.
We don't have sword fights anymore.
That's it.
Yeah.
We don't have no anymore.
No Musashi rolling around.
You know,
that was the reason why he was such a brilliant man about so many different
things with cause he had to be operating at full potential.
Impeccability you're fighting people would fucking swords,
man.
Jesus Christ.
He would always make people wait too.
Yeah.
He was kind of the content like that.
Musashi would always make people wait like hours before he showed up for these
duels so they'd be so mad.
They just charge out of him.
Then he would find the gift a couple of extra hours alive.
If you look at it that way,
giving up your extra foam is tales of people having to wake him up on the day he
was supposed to have a duel.
They have to wake him up and he would like leisurely eat a breakfast and then go
where the hooks are supposed to go.
That's scary.
Is there a scary of human?
No.
I killed like 62 people swords in one on one combat man fucking hey.
I mean to compare that to a fighter,
it's almost like a fighter who's never even taken a hard shot cause the
equivalent of a hard shot in a sword fight his death.
Well,
those days in feudal Japan to man real,
there was,
there was a lot of those Ronan's just wandering around bad ass sword fighters.
Like what the fuck man?
Could you imagine if a guy rolls into town and he's really awesome at killing
people,
but swords,
how fucking outfit is that guy going to be terrified of him?
This motherfucker wanting to the street,
he's got 16 desks.
He's looking at you.
He's got,
you know,
a little fucking skulls tattooed on his cheeks from everybody's killed.
Sees holy fuck man.
When back then there was no equalizers,
you know,
I mean people had barely embraced the Arrow,
right?
The Japanese weren't really in the guns.
They really,
especially back in the day,
they thought it was like,
uh,
like a cowardly way to fire,
which is really incredible when you think about it.
Like they were,
they didn't want to embrace guns initially.
Yeah.
Honor.
Honoring was more important.
Killing people with swords that it's gotta be the craziest fucking thing ever.
I mean,
that's why the Japanese culture,
the Samurai culture fascinates me so much.
What a unique exploration of man in his most terrifying environment and what he
does to steel himself for combat.
What he does to keep his mind pure,
what he does to stay completely in focus and in control of his emotions.
Wow.
And the s,
the answer is what he does is become a balanced man.
What he does is become emotional and write poetry.
What he does is become an artist and what he does is work hard and turn his body
into a fucking killing machine and he balances it all.
And at the moment of battle,
you remove all the emotions and find that zen space.
I mean,
those are the scariest buyers nowadays.
You could see it in some of these guys walking out the chaps like Anderson
Silva,
John John,
that kind of Uri calm where they're smiling and they look like they're high,
but they're not high.
They're just fucking in the zone like Zen.
That's fucking the scariest shit when people are pounding themselves in the head
and slapping themselves.
Yeah.
It's a little scary too.
They're making a big show of things,
but the fucking killers,
Anderson Silva was he the one got that in spades.
He's got it.
Yeah.
If you looked at it,
the one guy who's got,
you know,
fucking a full hand of aces,
but it comes to like his,
his mental ability,
his uh,
you know,
it's like,
it's,
it's almost like not even fair.
You know,
when Anderson Silva steps in and he's like super confident,
he's got this crazy look in his eyes were like,
this guy doesn't even look a little freaked out by the fact that he's in,
like when he went to fight rich Franklin for the title dude,
he's fighting for the title.
Okay.
I mean,
and he walks in the octagon and he,
it,
he doesn't even look remotely concerned.
Just didn't even look remotely concerned.
Who's fighting rich Franklin in the USC for the title and he looks like
completely calm and totally relax.
A guy who's got that ability to do that in the heat of combat and execute the
way he does.
That's so rare.
So rare that a guy comes along like that.
Like the last fight that he had with you,
she'll call me.
Did you see that fight?
That was,
yes.
Anderson Silva vintage.
The end of the first round,
he fucking head kicks Okami and all my God.
Yeah.
It just,
it just,
if it wasn't the end of that round,
I mean surely it would have probably stopped it in that round and he blasted him
with the fucking head kick at the end of the first round and then he'd just tees
off on him in the second you look at me go,
who the fuck has ever been better than this guy ever?
I mean,
this guy's better than people that are in movies.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
John Claude van Damme never beat anybody's ass like that.
Oh,
he up.
He got paid back.
You know,
when,
when Anderson like beat up,
you should have copies.
Like you should know Cami is a beast.
He's a tough,
tough guy.
Yeah.
And Anderson just lit him up.
But you know,
if he's coming from another place,
just another place.
And really that was actually part of understanding.
That was my third question
on this,
on this [inaudible] trip and it was about belief and it was he Anderson to get
to that point,
you have just infallible belief that you are going to win and when it's within
your control.
I think Bruce Lipton said it well too.
We do live in cope participation,
but for something that you are in control of,
if your belief is infallible in something like that,
but you are going to fucking win like you're going to win,
there's no doubt should have infallible belief and get in there with Anderson
still get lit the fuck up.
I don't think that,
I mean if you have a little stubby arms shit,
well then you get a tiny,
tiny job for sure.
If had take a shot,
that person really haven't fallible.
They would may think,
they may pretend that they have available,
but some part of him,
some deeper part of them all the way through the layers would know,
oh shit.
But then when we're admitting that it's genetically related,
it's client.
Oh,
sure.
Dot.
Infallible belief only comes with reality that comes with that.
It's not just a state of mind.
That's impossible.
That's right.
But also,
you know,
if,
if Anderson Silva believed that he could lose,
I think he very well may lose,
even though he has the genetics,
I think belief still is a key.
But yeah,
you don't,
there's a natural defense there.
You don't believe things that are just not possible.
I think Anderson believes because of experience and because of slightly he's,
he's,
you know,
it's not,
not esoteric crazy mind game.
No,
it's not massive belief in his abilities.
But you can't,
you can't deny that.
That having a strong belief in something,
it has a huge factor on things.
Even physical things,
even things that you would think would be like meet oriented,
you know,
wrestling and fighting and you know,
and things along those lines.
But no,
you know,
this is a huge factor and belief.
Belief plays a gigantic factor in performance.
Absolutely.
Your ability to take risks,
your ability to believe in yourself and in scrambles.
You know that your,
your ability to make sure that you always come on top.
A lot of that is mind.
Absolutely on a percentage of it,
100% but a lot of it is also the real thing is the discipline to fucking get
your body into condition because you can't,
that's everything else.
That one piece,
that's just the tip of the iceberg,
that kind of mental state.
You have to have a solid pyramid underneath that and that pyramid is built from
practice,
training,
experience,
hammering day in,
day out,
or is,
you don't get to have that little,
your pyramids all fucking Janky and not correctly form.
You only get to that sharp tip.
You know that final point is if you have everything else built,
UFC fighters are like modern day Samurais is what you're trying to say.
That's it.
Some of them.
Some of them,
yeah.
Some of them for real.
Yeah.
That's,
I mean that's to me,
I mean there's no other sport that's even remotely in the same league as it for
that very reason.
There's no other sport where everything is on the line like that.
Yeah.
You know,
you're getting to see these guys souls.
Yeah.
You're getting to see their conviction.
You're getting to see,
you know,
what they put put themselves through and conditioning and developing their
skills.
And I heard the last Living Samurai lists here in Los Angeles.
What's his name?
I don't know.
[inaudible] he teaches like classes,
downs down downtown.
Seriously.
Yeah.
How can you be the last Living Samara?
I don't know when,
when did the Samurai days then?
I think they made that movie about some crews.
[inaudible]
name's Tom Cruise who teaches a class college.
You have to be a [inaudible] saying that he takes Sam right classes.
And he was like,
well I think it ended with that last rebellion that they crushed with Mara Modo.
I mean that was based on a roughly loosely,
I don't even think there was an American involved,
but there was a Samurai rebellion of people who are kind of holding out for the
old way and they got crushed eventually by the imperial army.
So that story I think is,
is loosely,
loosely accurate.
And I think that was the late 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
Japan went through all those civil war civil war,
Huh?
Yeah.
Like 150 plus years,
right?
Yeah.
They had some serious conflict.
God Damn.
What a fascinating,
fascinating culture.
And to think that when you go there and now they're ridiculously polite.
You know,
when people were saying that's only because where are you?
Where are you guys were in a nice spa and I don't know.
I mean pretty much everywhere we went people seem to have like really nice
manners.
You know,
that was one thing I noticed like matters were like really at a very high
standard.
You know,
even like amongst security there's like they had no douchey knows.
Even the security guards,
it's honor when you have to hold yourself to standards of honor.
I think it's something that we've largely forgotten.
I mean,
honoring this code of honor and chivalry,
you have to treat others with respect,
even your enemies.
I mean,
treating your enemies with respect right now.
I mean our culture is more like treating your enemy with the fuck you,
you fucking Douche bag.
Uh,
you know,
instead of like [inaudible] but that's,
that's kind of the attitude.
But in Japan,
I mean everybody,
you know,
the more formidable your enemy the more you respect him.
He was a great,
we did this podcast we've seen with Sam Harris and Sam was talking about
meditative states.
It can be reached where you can actually recreate the feeling of being on
ecstasy.
And he said that what you would do is you'd first start meditating on your
friends,
your loved ones and love and the idea of love that you took.
You got to this extreme state and then you would turn that love instead of on
your friends.
You would turn it on,
anyone turn on any,
anyone that you could think of and then you turn it on your enemy.
Yup.
And that turning it on your enemy,
like turning all that love on your enemy is like the highest level of it.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
you know,
that was,
I listened to that podcast and that,
that was really interesting.
But it was funny to me to hear that that same guy talking about being in the
zone,
which is,
you know,
I was a basketball player and I know the zone and it certainly isn't every time
I make two jump shots.
So whatever tests they did for the zone,
it's not just you get in the zone for making two shots,
it just happens randomly.
You do that all the time if you're worth,
you know,
if you're a decent player.
But when you are in the zone,
and I think you were kind of hitting at it,
that is,
that is a moment where your mind is removed and you're allowed to,
your body just
does what it knows what to do and you can get there.
And every sport and when you do that,
usually a great result accompanies it.
But it's a certain way that you do things in which you're not fucking up and
sabotaging what your experience is capable of doing.
And that's a,
that is a phenomenon that exists.
I'm sure it's called dead stroke.
When you're playing pool,
you get in dead stroke or dead punch and you cannot miss.
And it might only last for one rack,
but whatever it is for that moment,
man,
you are fucking feeling it though.
The pocket may be a soccer goal.
You know where the cube walls going,
you have,
and it usually happens when you've been playing for like eight hours.
You pay for so long that you get in some sort of a weird half retarded state.
Well you become one with all your movements of your mind is just removed.
The most maddening thing to me about cool is that that state,
that state can be achieved every now and again and that you're always constantly
chasing that dragon.
Yeah.
Chasing that when you could just know you can just get out.
You just run out,
just run out and just keep running you.
I've heard it in pretty much everything.
Even non athletic things.
I think I did some little knickknacks stage acting in college and there was some
pretty good teachers there and the teacher was talking about another very good
stage actor just came out one night playing a fellow and just killed it.
Like had the most amazing performance ever and they went and talked to him in
the dressing room and they're like,
aren't you thrilled?
That was amazing.
He's like,
no,
I'm fucking pissed off because I have no idea how I got to that state.
Like he just found some groove where his mind wasn't thinking.
He wasn't analyzing what he was saying.
He was just being a fellow,
you know,
just really being,
so it applies to so many things beyond just athletics.
I know.
I know it exists because I needed to go on stage.
Yeah.
If I,
if I can't get into the zone when I'm on stage,
if I don't get in there,
if I'm not,
if feeling the material,
if I'm not like one with the whole thing,
then it's not the same show.
It's not,
it's not.
The audience knows it.
I can say the same words,
but if I'm not tuned into what I'm saying,
if you're not in that,
in that,
in that moment,
yeah,
it's,
it exists.
Man exists.
There's,
there's,
there's moments.
It's just,
you can't really measure them because they're so brief and you don't,
you don't,
even when they're happening though,
you know,
they're there.
Here's a perfect example.
There's a guy named Earl Strickland.
He's one of the greatest pool players of all time,
multiple time world champion,
just world world renowned pool player.
And uh,
there was a professional tournament where they had gotten a big insurance
policy.
The insurance policy said if anybody runs 10 racks in a row,
which is like virtually unfucking heard of,
there's only like a couple of guys who've ever done it,
ever nine or ten nine ball,
nine,
nine ball,
10 racks in a row is preposterous.
The idea that you break 10 times in a row and get a shot,
the one is preposterous.
The idea that you mean it includes nine on the brakes and includes,
you know,
uh,
combinations,
but the idea that,
that you could get out 10 times in a row is,
is preposterous.
Especially on like a professional table.
Yeah.
Well,
they put up $1 million and Earl Strickland smashed in 11 in a row.
You can't tell me that guy didn't get in the fucking zone.
No one's ever done that.
Well,
the only other 10 pack that I've ever heard anybody ever running was Johnny
archer.
He broken,
it was a a gambling session,
a famous gambling session with this fellow Filipino player,
Francisco Bustamante,
and he ran 10 racks in a row and then the Filipino tried to double the bet.
That's how,
that's how dangerous those guys gamble in the Philippines.
They know fuck made,
might've shook them out of the zone.
You know,
at that point he starts thinking about money.
He starts thinking about,
should I take it?
Should I make a deal?
Should I quit?
You know,
what about in my honor?
And then at that point,
you know,
that's when the fun thing about that you just rent 10 racks on a guy.
Now he wants to double up that.
I'm confident is this bitch,
you didn't even get there,
shoot for 10 whole fucking games.
You didn't even get to shoot.
He's just begging on the faculty.
But you cannot keep that up.
You're going to fall apart and you're going to go,
what am I doing?
Yeah,
you're gonna miss a ball.
They might not ever make a ball again.
Yeah,
no doubt.
Yeah.
This is someone exists.
It's just,
it's just impossible to test.
I mean,
so you could go ahead and test and he was saying what he was saying was he was
coming from a point of cold hard science and he was like,
if you look at what it is,
if someone hits like jump shots,
are they more or less likely to hit their next shot and looking at that at
numbers on paper.
I mean scientifically,
I see what he's saying.
I mean what he's doing I think is it's important to,
it's important to look at it from that angle as well.
The scientific method is good.
I just think the test is wrong because you could make three moments is unique.
How do you test those unique moment?
You could make five balls in a row.
It doesn't mean you're in the zone.
Maybe it just means that you made five balls.
Maybe the sixth one is harder.
You know,
being in the zone is different.
hitting two shots,
you hit two shots every fucking game.
Doesn't mean anything,
right?
But there's like,
there's a player like every now and then like you'll see in a basketball game.
Like you remember that kid?
There was a kid,
I believe that he was autistic and he was in a high school basketball game.
It just fucking sink in these jumps shots.
You remember this?
I remember that.
I mean you can't tell me something was going on there now.
[inaudible] zone.
Totally.
I mean that kid was like the zone a personified.
The audience is going Nazi just drain these flat three pointers like no,
no net or no,
no rim at all.
Just right through the net.
Every time to every amazing everything.
Even poker players just talking to this professional poker player,
Matt Van Grin and he was talking to him and he's like,
I know what.
I'm in the zone in poker.
I just know what to do.
I did.
My mind doesn't have to worry about it.
I know which way to go.
And you hit it.
You just existed.
And some almost impossible to test for.
And I think that's where you gotta be careful.
There's just because we haven't come up with the right test yet,
doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
You know,
it's like we're prying to apply tests that don't really work.
Like you could test a million grandma's and see if they can lift a car,
you know,
but unless
you're going to put their child underneath it,
right.
You know,
you can't see how much weight they can actually displace the test unless you're
some machiavellian evil sorcerer,
you know,
dictator.
You can't create tests that would put these people in these situations that
would create the moment,
that moment that defies,
you know,
statistical analysis.
Right.
Getting more zones.
I'm never in an zone.
It's like the only zones I'm in,
like school zones are phone zones,
but I've never needed like anything that,
that big of a zone that's your,
you live in a different life.
When was the last you got into?
Um,
I get in the zone.
When I do Jujitsu,
When I do comedy,
I get in the zone and I played pool.
If I played pool for like more than a couple of hours,
I can get into the zone.
Who's a hard one though?
It's hard when you don't play that often.
It's hard to get that dead zone.
Yeah.
That's a fun one though.
You don't get zone Brian,
because you're not out there doing anything with your body.
You don't move around.
You don't play the dance of the body and the mind,
the mind controlling the body.
You don't,
you don't go to yoga class.
What I'm saying Brian,
you know if there will work in your Kundalini,
you know out there trying to keep your shock or strong,
you're not out there doing that.
Oh,
you know what are you doing?
Smoking cigarettes.
Sleep until noon now.
Sure.
Got like some Asian.
I still my crazy.
How does that,
what does that,
my alarm clock's still fucked up in Japan.
I'm still waking up at like 6:00 AM for no reason.
And you do use your phone?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I mean I don't use my phone.
I just wake up and I can't go,
oh,
you're really your,
your biological clock fucked up.
Yeah.
And I and I still go to bed around why s like 1112 which I'm used to going to
bed like at four you know,
so my whole thing,
I can't change.
It sucks.
Whoa.
That's a,
it's an issue called your circadian rhythms are a bit off the,
actually I thought it was called t.
T.
E.
H gay.
Is there an audit pillow that I can take for jet lag this bad?
Well,
Methylcobalamin is,
Methylcobalamin is supposed to help with circadian rhythms a bit,
so you can,
it's in that shroom tech sport.
You don't work out.
That's probably why you're getting screwed by Brian Steroids for hours pick up.
You can just pick up methyl B 12 at any,
any she'd be working.
He knows how to do you get your notes for now?
Huge right now.
I'm going to pick it until I have a six pack.
No steroids.
Just
pinch it.
Play.
I got,
you know I get a big wheel from Brentley.
No,
Wilford Brimley.
Does he have a large homes?
I don't know.
It seems like it would.
It seems like you would with a name like Wilfred hiding it behind that mustache.
He probably has the biggest nose ever got her.
Yeah.
I mean that's why he's got this giant fucking tarpons tree underneath it to
distract from mind.
No.
So,
so I guess to go,
uh,
go on to question number four.
This is where it starts to get a little weird here.
Question four on.
So I'm lying on my back.
Things are pretty miserable,
but I still have that kind of blinking cursor of truth kind of pointing at
things.
Right,
right.
So everything to this point has been in words and I've kind of figured myself
out.
You know,
I talked,
I learned,
you know,
about differentiating fear from danger,
dangerous,
real dangerous,
something in pending.
It's about to happen.
It's a risk that you actually have and uh,
but and that's real.
But fear is an apparition.
It's false.
So you are poisoning yourself.
Poisoning myself,
most of the time.
I mean,
there's very few situations where you're scared of something that's actual
danger.
It's usually just fear,
which is fear is something to be obliterated.
There's no reason for it.
You mean acknowledging danger is a different thing.
So that was kind of a lesson.
And then again,
kind of what we were talking about with belief and just the power of belief,
believing what you are capable of doing.
I think other shamans call it intent as well as some of the Mesoamerican shamans
would call it intent and the we teach tradition,
it's belief,
um,
and,
and different things as well.
But whatever it is,
just believing and setting your intent for accomplishing something is one of the
most powerful forces acting within your control in the universe.
And it applies to a lot of things.
So I was pretty skillful.
Supernovas yeah,
I don't even need a lot of belief for that,
but I mean,
I think that isn't,
it is an active force in the universe.
And I think it's,
you know,
again,
difficult to quantify,
but you know,
you talk to the people who have achieved many things.
I think that belief component is,
uh,
is an invaluable component.
Yeah.
I mean,
if you want to make something happen,
you've got to believe in it and whatever it is,
whatever it becomes,
it,
you know,
might not have,
might not have been what you initially visualize.
Sure.
And what you initially were hoping for,
but you can steer it into a direction with intent and focus,
whatever it is that you choose to focus your energy on it.
Yeah.
It's just,
um,
for some people it's hard to find something they like.
For some people it's hard to find something that they're into.
You know,
it's a,
it's a difficult little,
uh,
yeah.
You know,
to say like you can,
you can choose to focus on something and you could be successful for some people
like,
and what,
you know,
there's a lot of people that,
yeah,
I agree.
And I think,
I think the key there,
I think there's a quote from,
from Cyrano de Bergerac and it's one of my favorite,
cause I'll do the,
would like he had the big deal.
He's a fictional character.
He was right.
Yeah.
Handsome man.
It was,
but it was,
it was a play by Edmund Rostam.
And so one of his characters quote,
so it's really an Edmund Ross Stan quote.
I use the original Milli Vanilli got to be healthy.
Um,
well he was actually writing speeches for,
for the other familiar middle.
Yeah.
Familiar with it.
But anyways,
he said,
you know,
I was puzzled with all of the many options that I had in life and I'm
paraphrasing because it written in French and then I decided to be admirable and
everything.
And so we really [inaudible].
So the idea,
the idea that is just maybe you don't know,
but maybe just be the best you can.
Whatever you're doing.
Yeah.
I think,
well,
it gives you satisfaction.
You know,
my happiness is always come from doing things well.
Yup.
Uh,
doing anything well,
whether it's playing pool,
whether it's doing a set of comedy or whether it's writing something that I
like,
whether it's,
you know,
whatever the fuck it is.
Yeah.
So
if you can't figure it out yet,
that's okay.
Yeah.
Just be admirable at what you're doing.
Practice doing things in a way that results in success and probably practicing
that by the time you find that channel that you want to tune into and kickass
on,
you'll have the experience.
Yeah,
maybe it's not in that same vein,
but you have experience in trying to be excellent and striving to be admirable
in whatever you're doing.
So I think that would be,
you know,
kind of the best advice for those people who haven't figured it out.
That's okay.
But just practice how to do it.
Once you figure it out.
I think people would like to take just a happy pill and just to sort of skate by
with a smile all day.
If you could give someone a pill and they'd be happy all day.
But I think you need to at least battle the lows to really truly appreciate the
highs.
You know what?
I really enjoy California when it rains.
That's what I really enjoy,
California cause it never fucking rains here.
It's garbage.
Never fucking raise.
So when it does rain,
I go,
Oh yeah,
we're lucky.
this is nature.
Nature just come down and dumps water on.
Everything from the fucking sky at is at its own discretion for as long as it
likes,
it pours fucking water on your head.
Like that's important to know that that exists.
And that's when I really appreciate California when I left spirit.
Anything you know remotely,
like whether that's the heart of Dallas philosophy without bad weather,
there is no good weather know.
I mean you have to experience both sides in order to appreciate the ones.
That's why Milwaukee has Summerfest.
Yeah,
cause they're fuck,
it's cold as fuck.
They're in the winter dude.
Yeah.
That's why it is.
They're so happy in the summer.
Yeah.
I did stand up there once a summer fest.
It was,
I felt so bad cause I gotta do my act.
You know I'm doing what I'm doing,
but I'm seeing people holding their babies.
People were in the background walking around holding their babies and I'm
talking about blow jobs.
I'm like,
wow,
this is wrong.
This is sad.
At one point in time that baby could have fit in that woman's mouth.
So don't feel bad.
You can't ever have a summer fest in California.
People were like,
bitch,
bitches somewhere on your own here when you talk to them about what we're going
to celebrate,
the fact that it's hot as fuck.
Same and same in Scandinavia.
I was there during summer where it's light 22 hours a day.
That's ridiculous.
Stoke cause it was dark for 22 hours a day for parking.
That's ridiculous too.
That's a shitty spot.
You people need to move.
Go to Burg.
I was out there and it was when it's dark all the time.
People lose their marbles,
right?
Yeah,
they'll go crazy.
What happens?
It's only like light for like three hours a day.
Yep.
And it's really,
it's just barely,
it's like,
it's not even real light.
Sun doesn't pass anywhere close to the top of this guy.
So it's just this little crescent or while you live in there.
But some people that need to realize that is not getting any better.
I'm really praying for global warming's what they're doing to like holding out
with hairspray cans blowing in the air.
I've got charts and graphs and shit.
Well as far as we've concerned,
like now we only have three or four more years before global warming becomes a
huge,
huge problem.
Look,
here's a chart,
here's the graphs.
Norway's looking good.
Just buy it up.
Coastal property.
While most of those places just fucking sink underwater anyway.
I mean that's,
that's what happened before.
That's what happened before.
Yeah.
Case it's a band aquanet cans.
They said there's thousands of cities that people have never discovered that are
just off shore somewhere.
Just sunk in when the,
when the uh,
the earth sea levels rose roles and felt were always like living right,
right next to the water.
And it's like whenever I drive by Malibu I think two things like wow,
how bad ass supposed to be to have a house like on the water.
Yeah.
That's pretty bad ass.
I have a friend who has a house in the water and we go over his house sometimes
and check them out and be like,
wow,
this is crazy.
Like he's got a house.
It's like right on the water.
I would want two houses though.
Cause that's also scary as fuck.
Don't you think?
Yeah.
Well it's his second house.
He's a wealthy man,
but his house on the water is like,
it's a tiny little house and it's like 4 million bucks.
I mean it's crazy.
You got to pay a lot of fucking money to get a house like on the water in
Malibu.
But Tim is so damn,
is it dope you seen on that back porch?
It's like you might,
this might be worth it.
This might be worth it to just sit there like
right there.
You're bed is right there by the ocean.
Are you kidding me?
That's bad ass.
What's our friend like?
Our one friend that owns the Comedy Cup,
Sal,
he has a boat and he just sleeps in the middle of the ocean.
He just drops his anchor the same.
I don't think.
No,
that's [inaudible].
I'm on the fucking read Pinocchio.
Yeah.
Wouldn't it be crazy though?
Just [inaudible] you feel a little funny.
That's a terrible off the boat flip over.
Drone houses can get jacked by tsunamis.
That absolutely can happen.
I totally look.
It's,
it's,
we're probably do,
I mean,
I hate to jinx everybody,
but you know the idea that it's been so god damn long since a significant
natural disaster wiped out of giant chunk of,
of life on this planet.
It's almost like a,
it's a little ticking time bomb.
Yeah.
Malibu House has bitch,
are you crazy?
You got a house right on the water.
How confident are you?
Did you,
did you not like go to school?
You'd see like pants barrier,
you know the whole,
the whole fucking continent used to be one thing and they're all separated.
Why you buy Pangea?
Yeah.
Why you bet Pennsbury is a meteors and carry life,
right?
Well,
I'm like,
why are you banking all your money on this one spot stand right there.
He's spent 4 million bucks hoping the door,
the ocean doesn't move in.
What does the ocean moves in?
You're out.
You just know more for 1 million bucks.
What happens there?
For real flood insurance underneath that water,
that section of water there was,
there was one beach in Malibu that was,
I think it was broad beach.
It's a like a very expensive,
it's all expensive.
The whole beach,
no Malibu beaches for expensive,
but this one broad beach area is particularly expensive because they have a
large section of sand.
So from their backyard,
it's a long piece of sandy beach and the ocean.
While someone did something apparently,
and this is all anecdotal conversational evidence,
I don't know exactly how this works.
Something changed
that they did like up up ocean or uptight or up current,
like up in like Santa Barbara.
There was something that was done and now all of a sudden it changed the way the
ocean comes in and the ocean now comes in deep into their beach and it's,
they've lost like most of their sand.
That's the bummer.
Yeah.
And that that can happen.
That's all [inaudible] to do is go up there and dig some shit and put up a
fucking wall somewhere and do something wacky that somehow or another changes
the current of the ocean coming down and now it takes a little steep left turn
and now you don't have a beach anymore.
Well,
yeah,
your house is gone.
If the polls shifted,
you know like they say that they may or something like that.
I don't know.
I'm not an expert in that.
But if the polls shifted,
is there a pull shifting expert out there?
I can help you out.
It's a real science,
right?
I think so.
I'm sorry if the poll shifted.
I think they have shifted before.
Yeah,
that's,
that's definitely,
I think they believe happened before.
You think it can happen again,
but then at that point,
I mean everything goes into,
most of the shit goes underwater cause all the glaciers melt and then it takes a
while for the new glaciers,
the form so that ice hasn't been buying bounded up and the egg are temporary.
The Poles,
the God damn thick,
thick as fuck.
They drilled into that Russian link,
Russian,
those,
those Russian science or the Antarctic Lake under miles of ice.
These Russian guys have been working for years and they finally just broke
through and drilled into this lake that got,
I forget the number of millions of years.
That was the last time this was exposed to light,
but there's a liquid water lake miles animal.
They don't know yet.
Hm.
Interesting.
Expensive fish.
It can be anything into there,
man.
You know,
who knows?
Buried under the,
people keep sending me this lake,
400 million year old fossil.
It's a machine.
It's 400 million years old.
The scientists and you look at it,
you're like,
that looks like,
like life looks like a fossil of like the bottom of some sort of like a jelly
fish or something like that.
Or you know,
or uh,
you know,
around cephalopod or what are those?
Uh,
those um,
sea urchins or something like that.
Like that's what it looks like.
Let's look like it doesn't look like a machine,
but people,
400 million year old machine.
Holy Shit Man.
Like,
whoa.
What are you trying to say?
It's funny that people get so stoked about some possible machine,
but really the most amazing machine possible was around 400 million years ago.
It's called fucking DNA.
DNA is 10 Adam's wine.
It's in every cell,
10 atoms wide.
And it would stretch for 125 billion miles,
25 billion miles.
That's in our DNA.
And so what they've identified is there's only somewhere between three to 10%
most bets are on 3% of your DNA that controls your genes.
And so they've isolated that and they figured a lot of shit about out about what
the DNA,
you know what parts of DNA control the genes?
Well,
90% maybe 97% of it,
they called junk DNA right now.
That to me is a pretty ridiculous thought and in and of itself,
because how would this survive through billions of years of natural selection?
If it was just junk,
don't you think you would kind of unraveling just the same?
It's just the same,
but they don't know when they have no idea.
Yeah,
but they don't really,
really think it's junk.
I think that's just like a [inaudible].
That's the saying.
Well,
they have because they haven't figured it out yet.
But they do call it that.
Yeah,
they call him John a colloquial term.
I think it's just,
they're being silly.
I think it's,
I don't know.
Maybe I may,
um,
I might be giving them too much credit apologists.
I think that's what they're doing,
but in any case,
they haven't quite figured out what it is.
And I,
and I was,
I think in a,
it was Graham Hancock's book to kind of shed light on some of the other theories
about when you apply that to,
uh,
to some linguistic theories,
basically saying that,
um,
there's a theory called zip or a phenomena called zip theory.
And that's basically that the word rank and the word frequency or directly
inversely proportional.
So that means like the word the has,
you know,
has a word rank of number one.
All right,
the second bit,
the second word that shows up the most is the word of,
or something like that.
And that will have half amount of occurrences in the language.
And if you stretch out enough books together as the word,
the,
and then the third one,
we'll have a third as many occurrences.
And this works not just for English,
obviously it's different words,
but it works for every single language.
It's called zip theory is zip,
Zip,
f theory here,
zip phenomena.
It's not,
it's beyond a theory because they've demonstrated a variety of ways.
And then so the DNA when they,
when they analyzed,
so the DNA that controls our genes,
the,
the part that controls our genes does not follow zip through it's way off the
charts because you a form of a straight line.
If you graph it by rank and frequency of the different codes,
there's these different dif,
different codes of the different um,
molecules that form up DNA,
nucleic acids.
But if you apply it to the 90%,
you know,
that's there,
then it follows linguistic zip theory phenomenon.
So basically the theory is that this is this some ancient and coding process.
It's an encoding process,
encoding and storing massive amounts of information,
more information than any machine could ever possibly record.
This 125 billion miles of 10 Adam wide language that's in all of ourselves.
And that kind of applies to a bit of what,
um,
you know,
there's some of these different shotguns and some of the theories are saying
that we're actually accessing knowledge that was previously hidden,
that's encoded in our DNA,
in this language,
the junk DNA part of our,
uh,
the language that's in the junk DNA part of ourselves that's encoding a lot more
really interesting theory.
But the point of all of that is,
yeah,
maybe that's,
maybe that's exactly what it is.
Maybe it's not,
but we are unbelievable.
Biotechnical miracle,
you know,
I mean,
the champions of technology.
Yeah,
technology is cool and we're doing some cool stuff,
but what's already in our body that we have no fucking idea how powerful and
what it's capable of.
I mean,
I think that will be the next true revolution in,
uh,
in technology.
After we figure out how to go faster and farther and whatever other nonsense
we're going to do,
we're going to eventually figure out,
we got to start unlocking what we're capable of and,
you know,
accessing those areas of the brain that we think don't do anything.
You know,
being able to uncode the DNA that we haven't figured out yet.
Do you think that places like this place you went to Costa Rica could exist if
they made I began legal in America.
I mean,
it sounds to me like there's a lot of legality.
I mean a lot of people would go nuts.
A lot of people would,
you know,
they would want to leave.
There would be like physical issues.
They'd be fucked up on this drug running around like maniacs.
You'd have to contain them.
You can't run.
Okay.
That's not a,
no one can run.
You can't get like one crazy dude.
He's got a weird times.
Let me tell you.
So I'm sitting there,
I'm asking all these questions.
I'm going to go back to soccer tops for the questions.
But let's say,
so at a certain point,
you know,
this was after I started thinking,
thinking about the earth and it was,
I was getting really nauseous this point.
So I pop up,
I pop up and I'm like,
I gotta Puke like this and this nausea was horrible.
Like,
Iowasca comes in a short wave and you go and it's out and you feel good,
you feel cleanse,
like ah,
that was a lovely vomit.
Or you take a good diarrhea shit and it's gone,
you know?
And no worries.
This was just like nausea,
like the worst food poisoning he ever.
So I sit up and I vomit and I take the blindfold off and lights are kind of
blinding my eyes.
I can't hardly see anything and I'm puking and it's just terrible.
I'm just retching up this acidic bile and it was awful and dry heaving and like,
do you do the worst spokesperson for this experience I have.
They're like,
well,
I learned a lot about myself.
[inaudible]
to the end.
Right.
Okay.
So then,
so then,
but it gets,
yeah,
this part is bad.
I mean,
this is not easy stuff.
So then I stand up,
I gotta take a Piss at this point too.
So I was like,
I stand up.
Why don't I just piss all over yourself?
[inaudible] man.
So,
so I go in,
I'm just tumbling and staggering to the bathroom.
Made a horrible,
like I can usually control,
and I'll ask you,
you could walk a tight rope,
you know,
you'd see funny shit,
but you're balance is not fucked up.
Like being super stoned right now,
like your balances and fucked up.
You've blasted to the moon.
Like you can sort of navigate,
I couldn't navigate shit like the world was spinning.
It looked like I was viewing through those old TVs channels that had the s the
horizontal lines of,
of static,
you know,
like,
yeah,
like all across the division.
And so I get to the bathroom,
I'm like stumbling around holding the walls and I'm going to take a piss and
then,
and I,
and I go and I'm like,
oh fuck,
what's going on here?
Cause I gotta take a Piss.
And I looked down and I have like the hardest Boehner I've ever had,
except it's just the opposite way,
just shrunk to it's miniaturist densest form of the tiniest.
And I was like,
what the fuck smalls?
You have your solid dick like pulled up inside just like fucking machine down to
the [inaudible] how small my Dick and look sometimes.
Oh yeah,
left.
It's really shocked.
Yeah.
Like I wouldn't want people to say,
even people that know it.
I know.
I mean this was like,
this was like unreal and I think maybe from the stimulant effect,
who knows?
But whatever.
I was like,
fuck,
this is bad.
So then I started to think at that point I was like,
all right,
maybe I should pick about pussy or something like that to you get to get
something working right now.
That's hilarious because you're scared because you dig so small.
[inaudible]
that was an even huger mistake.
That was a real truth rampaging in my head.
The minute the idea of pussy came in my head,
I started to try to understand pussy.
Oh,
and that is a disaster.
Nobody wants to understand pussy.
Like it's good to be admired from afar without seeing like the bio logical uses
of every different part of it.
So anyways,
that was a fucking,
that was a fucking nightmare that luckily I got that out of my head before I
ruin things for for awhile,
but then crash back to bed.
But the physical,
what did that experience smelling smelled like?
The fucking,
probably the vomit that was coming out of my mouth,
but the physical experience,
the whole point of that being the physical experiences.
Brutal.
I mean your body is going through some serious,
some serious work,
but your mind,
your mind is just on this fucking beautiful channel that you can access things
that are really remarkable.
Do you think that this interface that you saw where it was almost like a cursor
and you move it,
was that influenced by your own experience with computers and he think that it
was like implanted like,
well this is an easy way to describe it to him.
Let's just show it to him.
Like totally.
I think,
I think a lot of this stuff is just coming from what's best to explain to you
how does the most familiar way he's used to as a computer's total click on this.
Totally.
And that's how,
and that's,
and that's how it comes to you.
And that was very evident to cause everything else up,
up to three first three questions were,
were voice,
like I said.
And then I was like,
all right,
I want to focus beyond myself and you know,
really kind of get out there.
And so I started asking questions about other phenomenon.
So I was like,
all right,
why not go for the fucking,
the Big One?
What's the nature of God,
the universe and infinity,
you know?
And so immediately I started getting this image of the universe and planets and
these planets,
we're like bursting out like the big bang.
And I could see him,
I could see him coming from a point and then differentiating Bam out.
And I saw him pushing out into this nether,
into this void that was like dark matter and the dark matter,
you know,
it seemed like nothing but it had just the mildest resistance,
to it.
And eventually this burst,
this big bang goes out and it runs out of energy.
And when that runs out of energy,
everything starts to suck back in.
Slowly,
slowly,
boom,
and goes back into another,
into another point,
which is another big bang.
So it's like,
and so I saw that and I was like,
whoa.
So this is like,
you know,
this happens on a cycle.
And then I was like,
I got it.
That makes sense.
So this infinite big bang,
like a heartbeat of the universe.
And then that,
then that clicked and then when I saw was this giant kind of electronic tighten
that was like running in,
the Titan was running and the universe was like,
it's heart inside.
And I was visualizing,
it's like crystal fucking clear,
you know,
no words this time.
This is just the images and the Titan is running.
And his act of running was what was keeping the heart pumping.
And that is what it told me.
That was the nature of God was this Titan.
And the reason all that God is doing basically is running,
you know,
he's running so that life can exist so that the heartbeat of the universe will
continue.
You know,
he's,
no,
he's not making decisions.
He's not deciding whether the Denver Broncos beat the fucking colts or whoever
else.
You know,
people think that this got up there is trying to do,
no,
he's doing the important thing which is continuing to run and continuing to let
that heartbeat of the universe go and allow there to be life.
And that was a force behind it.
And so that,
I mean this is getting kind of really out there,
but it's it show,
it just comes to you.
These,
these answers come to you in these questions.
And then at the point and I was like,
all right,
well what do they need?
This is like stuff you already knew from school age maybe may sort of certainly
certainly created by your imagination.
Loyal to the staff saying that this isn't anything but the best thinking I've
ever done on uh,
on topic.
I don't think there has to be any,
even when I'm going to,
I'm going to talk about talking to other people.
I don't think it necessarily means that I have to be actually talking to them.
What is getting an understanding?
Is it a mechanism for you and understanding things?
I feel like a Bogo is now with Iowasca.
I really felt like there was something other,
like I was going to something with a Boga.
I can explain all of it by just the very,
my very best thinking on any topic that I pointed you thinking that I would not
be capable of without,
without it in a bogus situation.
So,
you know,
so sort of finish that.
And then the nature,
I was like,
what about the nature of infinity?
And then boom,
like,
and I think you even have a comedy bit on this and,
and it's about the infinite,
you know,
parts of the universe.
There wasn't just one titan,
you know,
there was thousands of titans and they were all running around on a circular
track.
And that's the nature of infinity,
this heartbeat in as many universes as you can imagine.
And as many heartbeats as you can imagine running forever.
Well,
if you just think of how big the fucking solar system is,
just the solar system,
just to shit that we know,
just what we have pictures of it.
You can't even wrap your head around how many miles that is,
how far away it is.
You get to fucking Neptune in your car,
you know,
you can't even wrap your head around it.
It's beyond belief that anything can truly be that far.
Yeah.
Now realize that that is a fraction of a galaxy and then not even a very bad
galaxy.
A normal size galaxy.
Yeah,
and then even in the center of every galaxy,
there's a supermassive black hole that is one half of 1% of the mass of the
entire galaxy.
The bigger the galaxy,
the bigger the black hole.
And they believe inside every one of those supermassive black holes may very
likely be a whole nother universe with hundreds of billions of new galaxies,
each with black holes and that.
That's how the universe is structured,
that the universe is massive,
impossibly large things that are inside of massive impossibly and he'd just goes
on and on and on and that fractally forever.
Yeah,
that's an that.
But it sounds,
when people say,
that's crazy,
that's not,
how is that possible?
That sounds like nonsense,
but what are you talking about?
It all sounds like nonsense space sounds like nonsense.
The God damn moon sounds like nonsense.
There's a giant fucking rock that could fall on us and smashes to bits and it's
flying over our fucking heads every day and we're like,
oh,
look,
the moon,
if that fucking thing fell out of the sky,
it just dropped on us.
It is a fucking miracle.
It's floating in the air above us.
It's gigantic.
It's made out a rock.
It's 260,000 miles away and it's fucking huge.
It's one quarter the size of us and it's just floating above us.
Just flying through fucking space right above us.
If that alone doesn't give you a little wake up,
this is all crazy.
You think there couldn't be a universe inside every black hole?
How is there a black hole?
How is there a universe?
It's all fucking nuts.
Of course there could be stupid.
It could be nuttier than that.
It could be.
It goes the opposite way deep down into your own cells,
into your fucking string theory.
It could be anything.
It could be massive,
massively small or massively large,
impossibly large or impossible.
The small and that was this.
So,
so how this came to me I think is interesting because everything else before was
words.
It was,
it was not so much like something was speaking to me,
but I was cognizant of it in words.
Everything else that Kinda came,
this was pure pictures.
It was almost like words are not going to fucking help you out here buddy.
Like so I'm going to give you straight images on this question and that was this
kind of work.
What kind of images?
That was the image of the heartbeat of God,
the Blue Titan running around this track.
You know,
that was the only way,
I guess from my mind to be able to grasp it.
Sounds like an awesome movie.
Yeah,
that sounds like a really cool episode of the watch.
Sweet.
I would really love to get it like animated by a cool cause I have it perfectly
visually.
Really bad dude.
I bet somebody to be willing to do it.
[inaudible] circus guy.
Explain it.
Explain again.
What does that look like?
So what is the vision?
Giant Blue Titan.
It's kind of a little bit,
it's almost like it's made up of limited picks.
Like it's not very well to see a tight like a giant,
like a just a giant,
like an old giant,
giant,
giant Greek mythology,
green color.
But it's blue going cloths are no blocks blocks like pixelated.
Exactly like large translucent pixels and you could see through its body just to
the heart doesn't have anything else but the,
but the prison and the art and the heartbeat of the universe is boom is pumping
and flowing out and all the planets are going out and then coming back in big
bang retraction,
big bang retraction and it's,
and it's running just steadily.
Same.
CBD to money is some mind fuck of all time.
The nuttiest mind fuck of all time is that,
you know,
even though we,
we understand this
concept of the universe being infinite and we understand this concept of,
of each individual black hall having universes inside of it,
what if all of that,
all of that is just a part of something that's going on inside the atom of a
much larger bullying.
Yeah.
And that really does go on above that as well to this much larger being being in
a galaxy,
being a part of another universe that's above.
I mean,
if this exists,
why not that as well?
Why not infinite,
infinite progressions of it and where do we just can't be aware of it.
We know we could barely deal with life and being aware of what we are aware of
currently.
Right.
It's too much,
too much that you kind of mentioned that tuned in to all the other dimensions.
So all of a sudden the scientists have this new fucking television set cause a
giant Sony TV and they're fucking just cranking this dial and tuning into next
dimensions and you get to watch the impossible.
You do watch a world where physics doesn't work the same in a world where
everyone's made of light.
Yeah.
You know what if the government always lied about how far space was really like
NASA and like all that shit was bullshit and that we would go there all the time
but only select few would go onto the other side.
Like spaces only like I dunno,
like two hours up in the air and the whole time they just lied about how far the
sun was,
how far that the moon was.
Cal [inaudible] knows how far the Moodle because you're told by the government
scientists black helicopters.
Okay,
interesting.
Crazy.
Seriously Sherry,
I don't know.
I don't know if I could ride with you on that.
He's getting back my ride shotgun.
I'm now getting back at me from my intelligent kangaroo theory.
That's what he's doing.
I know what the fuck he's doing.
He says this is revenge tree yesterday.
Yeah.
Yesterday I was saying we'll,
we allowed Kangaroos to get like super smart,
like kangaroos started eating some leaf and all of a sudden they started
figuring out the world and using tools and we drove by the kangaroo colony and
they're fucking welding and shit and putting together armor and what would we
allow that the fuck no would have kangaroos made swords and came into town.
We would never allow that.
Now we don't,
we don't allow other intelligent life forms to,
to exist and to be running shit.
What if you could talk and this other side and that they work for those people
that get to live on the other side.
And they sent the cats as like a security guard to watch what we're doing like
and like I really like high end video camera.
What size is 24 hours on a bug?
I couldn't follow that.
What's up with the Egyptians?
Loving cats.
Why do they love cats?
Exactly.
That Graham Hancock goes into that a little bit.
These theory in theory and Morphs,
I believe he calls them these half few line half,
um,
half people basically gods that come out as a spirit teachers.
And I think it's related to the God.
Um,
oh,
what was it?
Um,
you,
Boston [inaudible] was the Greek cat got,
I mean the Egyptian cat got name was Boston and it was one of those figures that
would,
uh,
that would appear to them.
You know,
actually I started thinking about Egypt when I was,
when I was on this,
uh,
on this ship.
This is one of my later,
very later questions.
I was like,
how the fuck did they build the pyramids?
And,
and really good fuck yeah,
I was honestly just like at the end,
I mean you're under so long,
you're just trying to think of shit to think of it as.
I was like,
all right and then what I really,
what it's when it started to tell me was it was like,
well you underestimate how much,
you know,
an unlimited multitude of people linked together,
unified to trying to do something as if their life depended on it can
accomplish,
you know,
like how do they move?
There's 10 ton block.
Well there was fucking 20,000 of them who would be killed if they didn't move
it,
you know,
so they just fucking put enough ropes,
kind of this Gulliver's travels type of thing and they put enough ropes and link
them enough together and have enough people playing tug of war and pulleys and
whatever it is.
You have these ropes that extent.
I saw this image of these ropes that extended for,
you know,
like a mile.
I don't know how long it really was.
It was a vision,
but it's a p everybody kind of pulling together unified as if their life
depended on it.
And that's how a lot of this shit got got done.
It wasn't as esoteric as maybe a,
we want to think.
It was just,
just underestimating that many people working together with that kind of intent.
Yeah.
But then I'll have to understand what was going on.
They'd all have to be,
uh,
some of them,
some of them would.
So there was like the supervisors that knew how to set up the pulleys and how to
attach the right knots that could support a string of 40,
you know,
150 slaves.
Well,
obviously someone did it somehow.
Yeah.
I mean,
my,
my thought has always been that they probably had some technology back then that
white was wiped out with their civilization.
You know what I mean?
Essentially,
at one point in time,
the,
uh,
adoption pyramids and when you would,
you know,
there's the Sphinx,
like when I believe when a Napoleon found it,
it was like covered it.
It was the sphinx covered again and it was covered by sand.
There was nobody living there.
Yeah,
right.
Wasn't that what was going on?
Not sure on the details possible that the people that built those things knew
more than we think.
They knew.
A lot of that information was lost in the burning of the library of Alexandria.
I think they probably had some machines that we don't give them credit for.
But the most interesting thing that I've read recently is about pyramids is that
they believe that the stones were actually cast.
And this guy,
um,
he links the water profile of these stones,
to,
uh,
the difference between,
um,
straight limestone and straight a granite and you know,
whatever different,
what,
what do they make,
what does most of the pyramid made out of,
I know the outside was like a smooth limestone,
but what are the most of the,
whatever,
whatever they're made out of,
whatever the fuck they made out of.
Um,
this guy has demonstrated that this can easily be made as a cement and they
could cast it,
which makes a lot more sense.
Like bricks.
Yeah.
And then the,
you know,
that's how it was made so perfectly.
That's how these molds,
I mean,
there was one mole surgery.
They certainly were doing some unique things.
I mean in in the mega list,
in the mega list and Peru,
you know,
the way that they are creating these,
cutting these stones out,
they had some tricks up their sleeve.
I'm not,
they had a me
amazing tricks up their sleeves.
Yeah.
Just the,
the fact that they,
the Great Pyramid of Giza is a marvel.
I mean,
there's no one,
no one today has recreated that.
I mean,
not to say that they couldn't,
I mean my possible,
but God damn wood,
we'll pick a piece of work that is 2 million,
300,000 stones and some of them,
they're weird.
Like I think it was the big ones in the king's chamber.
They get up to like 80 tons or something.
Fucking crazy.
Jesus Christ.
A lot of slaves that,
a lot of slaves.
[inaudible] what a bad ass civilization.
They were amazing.
You know,
when you really stop and think about these people were living like 2,500 BC,
they were rocking it like this.
That's just incredible man.
You know what I was,
another cool thing I got out of the supernatural was that usually we think of
King Tooton comments to is unmuted.
Completely on looted,
right?
It was don alluded in modern times,
but in antiquity it was looted once and the only thing they still,
there's mad gold in there.
Like we've covered everything from their gold,
riches,
whatever,
but they had 400 liters of a special liquid that was buried along with it and
common.
And they found that,
um,
the residue that makes them believe that it was a common,
it was their potent psychedelic combination of mandrake water,
lily and poppy.
And uh,
the residue that they found on some of these urns leads them to believe that.
And that's the only thing that was jack from and comments to him.
So that was like the magical feral elixir that allowed them to see all these
area morphs and have,
have these visions of people crossing the other side.
And even on King Ramses to them there's a most fucking mind blowing thing ever.
It looks like it's called the men with the twisted chords and it's like these
dudes holding a DNA strand and they're like part of the gateway between life and
death.
And you look at that and you're like,
that's fucking DNA.
Like men holding like in a line,
like just holding these twisted cores that look exactly like a double helix.
I've seen very Egyptian style things on DMT.
I've seen very Egyptian style,
like a physical imagery.
You know,
I think the,
uh,
there,
there may be something to these visual experience that people have while they're
on these visionary plans that it gets etched into the experience.
And so like when you're taking mushrooms and you close your eyes and you see
like Mayan temples and shit like that.
Yeah,
it might be because you're absorbing the experiences of these fucking people
that lived in the Mayan temples,
to be honest.
Show your,
your,
your house does look like in Egypt,
a ride at Disneyland.
So
I think you would definitely have to think about Egypt shit here.
Yeah.
Here for sure.
That does well more Tibet really in and do stuff.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Fascinated by all that stuff.
Now I think a lot of the,
the visions that these people,
uh,
have had to create certain things,
certain,
uh,
you know,
like different,
these,
this common atory creature that exists in so many different psychological or a
psychedelic states rather,
um,
where it's an animal and a person combined.
And there's like
so many of those,
there's a,
you know,
from the old caves,
it's Uva.
Yeah.
And is the month,
years ago,
yeah.
All took to,
you know,
more recent cultures.
Yeah.
There's all of these myths.
Oh,
I just,
what is it something the fuck is that all about?
So whether,
whether,
so there's a couple of different ways you can look at it.
Either,
you know,
and Graham Hancock posits this,
either these supernatural entities actually exist,
you know,
out there and you're actually accessing your communicating with them.
That's certainly one possibility.
One hypothesis.
They exist in a dimension that you're tuning into that frequency,
that dimension,
and they're really there.
That's why people keep seeing them.
The other thing would be that,
and,
and this is kind of a little bit more where I'm starting to fall into,
is that you're trying to translate information and that information is coming
through something that's very difficult for your cognition to understand.
So teachers,
patterns of different teachers that are trying to tell you something,
appear to you,
you know,
and they appear to you to kind of tell you things,
guide you,
things,
show you things.
And there's some commonality into what we see and manifest from these truths
that we're trying to get from the other side.
And it's just kind of,
uh,
translation technique that showed that knowledge comes into us and slams against
our filter and creates these area.
Morris,
he's half people,
half,
half.
Gotcha.
So it's almost like it's a different language and this is how we're discipling
it.
It's like when you go to Google translate and you throw in something,
somebody says,
like,
somebody will say something to me in Portuguese from Brazil and I go,
I don't know what they do.
Just said,
let me go check this out.
And I'll go.
And it's always like the translations crazy.
It's always wonky,
you know?
Because it's never,
it never comes across like an English sentence because the language is
completely different.
Yeah.
It's like so that's probably what we're doing.
So the like the,
the,
the experience and the information and the knowledge is real.
It's just being presented to you through a way that the universe believes you'll
understand and that way is created by your imagination.
Right?
I think it's hitting your own,
hitting your own filter and so that's why you don't care if you're talking to
people in your psychedelic experience,
if they're real or not real,
what you care is that you are getting something out of the experience the way
you would if you were having a conversation with a real person and that the real
benefits are there,
whether it's some sort of a mechanism that this,
this higher intelligence has plant based,
higher intelligence is using to transfer information to you or whether or not
you're really fucking talking to dead people,
that that doesn't matter.
What matters is that you're getting out of this,
what you would get out of this if you were talking to a wise dead person.
Totally.
And then why is this the key?
Cause Terence Mckenna once said,
just because someone's dead doesn't mean they were smart to never listen to
ghosts.
[inaudible]
I always thought that was great because I fucking would hate it when people
would sit around and fucking hold hands and channel and you know,
and then some,
some voice from beyond would give you advice and just cause your dad.
Does he imagine if you're talking to some dead person that was just really
stupid,
they were dead and they just had these run on sentences,
but there was so happy that anybody was listening to them because now all of a
sudden they're special in the real world that would tell boring fucking
sentences.
He,
their,
their conversations were deaf.
Like people come over all here,
this motherfucker comes and people would rub.
But as a ghost,
like now he's the shit,
you know,
as a ghost.
Like you could show up and fucking TV shows will be written around this asshole
talking.
You know,
if he showed up on ghost hunter and start talking to people in the basement and
they're like,
holy fuck,
this is a head.
There's a real ghost ghost hunter.
Like,
Yo man,
I'm cute now.
You know,
people love to hear me talk.
You guys said I was a run on and then fuck you.
Okay.
Because a lot of people think would have to say is very interesting.
Imagine if that was a ghost.
Every ghost,
the only goes through allowed his people that were so annoying that they didn't
want them in the afterlife.
So they got to the door and they got kicked out.
So that would go so far as people that are hanging out on the front lawn of the
afterlife when if his name is kangaroo Jack Kangaroo Jack,
what is that?
It's a movie
knowing kangaroo Ian movie from the 80s I remember that.
What do I remember that?
I don't know.
It's really annoying.
I go,
what if George,
our banks wiser guys?
You know it's,
it's,
it's man,
it's a tough call when you start trying to figure out what's real and what's
just these tools and information,
but you know,
emote it Boga Bogo definitely points you in and the other stuff though,
man,
it gets hard.
That's why when you're doing I WASC and things,
it's hard not to really truly believe that there are other dimensions out there.
At least the DMT experience,
which is essentially the same as the I lost keeps parents,
although more intense and short,
it is the hallmark of the experience to one almost universal description of it
is that you are encountering someone,
you are encountering something you encountering,
you are,
you are encountering an incredible intelligence.
You're encountering something that thinks everything's funny,
you know,
and they're all,
really across the board though when you're on these,
one of the truths that comes through that's very almost impossible to,
to debate once you're under,
underneath and you've been enough of these trips is the existence of an infinite
soul of something that transcends the body,
that the body is just really truly a vessel.
And so if there is that thing,
which is,
you know,
impossible for me to escape from an experiential things on a variety of
different,
different ways,
um,
you know,
then that has to have some kind of other dimensional dimension,
if you want to call it,
uh,
certainly where that,
you know,
kind of where it operates.
So,
you know,
I think it's hard to imagine there not being another dimension,
but are there half lion,
half man,
you know,
apparitions or half dog,
half man,
like a new bus,
you know,
are these real or are these,
translation tools.
You know,
maybe there's just us and then their souls because I know I,
I really feel like I know that,
you know,
cause I've seen it too many times.
I've seen souls.
Have you seen souls?
Well,
I've seen my own,
I've see all my own very early on,
which kind of started me on this whole journey very early on.
I saw my own lift out of my body.
That dream.
No,
under a psychedelic experience.
We won.
I was on mushrooms
and Syrian room.
I believe in a,
what is someone who isn't Syrian Rue and Mao inhibitor that Jesus Christ is an
intense,
oh my God,
you're not supposed to do that.
I'm not recommending any elicit from folks at home.
Mckenna had this,
uh,
this,
talk once where he was describing what happened when he combined mushrooms and
Iowasca then he fucked up.
Cause you know,
Iowasca also has an Mao inhibitor and Mao inhibitor apparently makes mushroom
the mushroom experience much stronger.
And then with the Iowasca as well,
all this together like literally was losing his mind like was watching his
memory getting eaten up in front of a destroyed.
That's a bad,
that's a bad experience.
Those I,
I dunno,
whatever,
what has happened to work synergistically?
So I watched my dad worked like in what way?
[inaudible] son it completely eradicated fear of death.
Well eradicated for your desk.
I mean,
and that's a huge obstacle for a lot of people.
[inaudible] UFC,
bro [inaudible] injury.
Are you having any side effects from all this shit?
Like are you looking at like a blank laws that looked like a blank wall or is it
looked like a floor more,
more,
more happy?
It really is the only side effects that I've,
that I've encountered.
But this one,
this one,
early on being able to see my body distinct from my,
from my spirit,
that was something that I,
and I've reinforced,
reinforced that and further further experiences.
But that was something,
uh,
that was something pretty unique.
And then,
uh,
and then from there,
you know,
I learned different things.
I made some,
that was a pretty powerful trip for me actually to,
not to digress from my,
at Boga trip when at that point I realize some synergies between the heaven and
helmet because I realized that once the soul leaves the body at that point you
have really perfect clarity on looking back at your own life.
I totally interrupted you.
What were you saying when I,
when you,
when you were what,
what were you on the path of saying,
well,
you were talking about the Syrian root.
That was an early experience with a shaman in Mexico actually.
And how old were you?
2012.
So that was easy.
That was 11 years ago.
I mean,
a lot of these initiates shit bogus.
Sharman I went to,
he started doing a Bogut
nine oh Jesus.
Nine [inaudible] it'd be upset.
You've still got to kind of remember when you stole that candy.
His grandfather know nine years old.
But for me it was
first one was 20 and that experience was invaluable.
And then I was able to separate my body from my soul and realize that this is
just a temporary thing and then make some synergies to about what heaven and
hell really was.
Heaven is when you leave your body and you can look back on your life and say,
God damn,
I did a good job.
I did the best I fucking could.
Yeah,
I fucked up sometimes,
but I lived a good life.
I treated people well and the earth and the people in it were better for my
existence and that feeling of kind of,
you know,
love and gratitude as you're being kind of sent back to the spirit world.
That's a blissful,
ecstatic feeling.
Just feeling,
just expressing them when you said just now,
right now,
to just plant that thought into the ideas of,
into the minds of people.
Plant that idea into,
into your,
into your everyday view of life that the best way to live life is just to do
your best and be cool to people and be nice and get through this as easy as you
can and it can be done by all of us can't.
That's the one thing,
if you're not some fucking serial killer right now that needs to turn yourself
in.
You know,
almost virtually anybody can turn their shit around.
Virtually anybody can put themselves on a positive path.
It's just so fuck that were denied the use of the psychedelic compounds and
denied their use in this sort of clinical setting.
I mean,
they can have you and bring you to fucking rehab and you know,
take you a Malibu and you know,
you,
you're hanging out on some fucking place and they give you,
uh,
a spring tea with lemon juice in it and you know,
and you detox yourself and you try to talk about your feelings and why you are
really getting down with cocaine.
I mean,
but,
and then you have a 10% success rate in your,
you know,
not going to really fix you.
Okay.
The sitting around and just,
it just not being on the drugs.
That's not really gonna fix you.
It's gonna like make you relax and then you get this point of instability and
you're going to get the itch again and you're going to look to fill up a void,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's your childhood,
it's your genetics,
it's whatever,
whatever it is.
Whether it's a physiological addiction or psychological addiction,
you're going to run and try to stuff that whole.
Right,
and that's that,
that that's,
it's a sad,
sad thing that we know this now for essentially for a fact that John Hopkins
University study on Psilocybin and the proof,
or at least the demonstration that it changed people's personalities.
Just one trip 20 years ago changed their personalities.
I mean,
come on,
man.
Isn't that what we want?
Don't we want a better world?
I'm on nicer people want it,
need it.
We need a goddamn president to come on television and say,
we need to incorporate the psychedelic experience back into our people in order
to foster the ideas of love and kindness and compassion and community,
the true feeling of community,
not just as an esoteric idea,
not just as an abstract notion that you sort of pay credence to,
but as a real community,
a community of,
of loved ones,
people who have shared the same experience,
people who feel the same way that you do,
the agreement that they'll be just as cool to you as you are to them.
You know,
because we really are one crazy fucking super organism that can be achieved.
It's just,
I don't,
I mean,
look,
you look back on what's,
you know,
what's taken place just in the last couple of hundred years,
a couple of hundred years is nothing,
but you know,
there was slavery,
there was crazy.
There's civil war and there's all kinds of nutty shit a couple hundred a couple
hundred years from now.
It's not outside the realm of possibility that some bad motherfucker introduces
the concept of psychedelics back into culture.
And a completely eradicates this whole system of corporate influence and ruining
the environment and everything is done ethically from then on out.
Everything is all energy is focused in a way that can never be greedy,
that can never be monopolistic.
That it is entirely possible if we keep psychedelics around and keep the open
exchange of information around on the Internet and you know,
we don't blow ourselves up.
If we can pull that all together.
It's only a,
it's a matter of,
it's a matter of how deep it gets into the culture.
I mean,
it's already been introduced into the youth.
Youth of today are a completely different animal than the use of just 10 20
years ago.
They're completely informed.
They're bad motherfuckers.
A 20 year old kid today.
You can't sleep on a 20 year old kid today.
They know way more than I did when I was 20.
I've had some conversations with 20 year old kids and go,
what the fuck dude?
You really 20,
what's real legal sleep with a 20 year old kid?
How dare you?
How dare you Brian?
Um,
you threw me off,
but not,
but not doing things.
Not allowing this to happen is worse than it's worth than just preventing people
from their best.
It's actually preventing.
It's condemn it evolution.
It's really condemning them to a certain hell is what I realized in this first
one.
It's condemning them to the hell of they're going to,
they're going to die at one point and all these misconceptions and all of the,
all of the bullshit excuses and rationalizations that they've been using to beat
their wife or whatever fucked up thing they'd been doing.
Oh,
she's,
she's a fucking stupid.
She needs to learn whatever.
I'm just using a bad example maybe,
but whatever bad thing,
bad,
he's a dick.
Yeah,
well that,
well,
whatever bad thing that,
that,
that person has allowed himself to do has rationalized himself to do.
When he dies,
he's going to look back and go,
oh,
fuck,
oh fuck,
I was a dick.
I hurt this person and they're going to relive every single moment of their
wickedness with God's gods.
I clarity,
you know,
that perfect infinite clarity back on their life.
And that's how,
that's how having to think,
I did this me,
stupid fucking me did this and that takes a long time to forgive.
Well,
I think that's that that held concept that's actually based in something real.
I think the use of,
in the lessons learned from humbling experiences,
whether they're physical experiences like rights of manhood,
you know,
rights of manhood,
uh,
things,
challenges that people have to go through,
like the real passages where they feel real,
but then there's a reason why they're engineered.
I think a lot of religions and a lot of tribal societies,
these rites of passage and you know,
they're not always,
they're not always sane.
Like some of them are fucking crazy,
like the new Guinea ones where they have to drink loads of,
you've heard of this?
No.
Oh,
did you pull this up on Google?
Because it's the most ridiculous thing ever.
And a new Guinea men have to,
uh,
to,
to become a man.
They have to give fucking blowjobs new Guinea tribe.
Hold on.
Oh,
it's the most disgusting thing ever.
It doesn't even make sense.
Hold on,
I'm pulling it up on me,
but that's just the gay dude try.
But it's a whole fucking community of Gab.
But I've,
I've heard of,
I've heard of fraternities who have some similar stupid shit,
but that's really just like a couple of gay people in the right position at the
right time that decide,
that make this the ritual.
Like you could have chose something that,
and this is,
this is real shit man,
and this is a freak,
this,
this really freaky,
but it's real.
This is going on right now today.
Bazaar,
homosexual rights.
Our practice extents extensively by numerous Melanesian in New Guinea and
adjacent islands.
Young boys must accumulate semen for several years,
either by regularly receiving anal penetration or by swallowing the ejaculations
of older males.
They pholate this ancient custom springs from a religious belief system that
regard sperm as the essential conduit of masculine energy.
Puny Boys,
they believe are only transformed into virile warriors if they ingest large
quantities of sperm.
Oh my God,
Christ sat culture,
I'd be willing to bet does not have a psychedelic component to their belief
system.
By the way,
these guys are all so fucking head hunters,
the roofless sparkly outfits living with the truth.
But I think that just goes to show how if someone gets in early and sets up some
kind of tradition,
like a lot of these world religions,
they just got in early and they got some momentum early and that momentum will
perpetuate itself in ridiculous hours for thousands of years.
It'll just go on because they got it early.
They convince people and those people tell their kid,
go on what most people tell the kid.
And at a certain point,
after you've blown,
you know,
505 minutes,
when you're an old man,
you're like,
where's my blow jobs?
You know it's going to happen.
You're going to impose that on the other.
So it's this bad kind of karmic momentum that gets developed.
Listen to how crazy this is.
It's not just one tribe.
Okay.
This is 10 to 20% of all tribes and Melanesia and Osha and Oceana region
stretching 3000 miles from Iranian Jarrod,
Jarrod to Fiji,
have mandatory.
This is fucking 10 to 20% have mandatory boy inseminating practices.
Boys are separated from their mothers when they're seven to 14 years old and
installed in bachelor houses in quotes.
And,
uh,
the,
the merind anem of southwest New Guinea who were ruthless headhunters.
Also.
These guys are fucking head hunters are savages are crazy.
And they're fucking boy.
They give the boys to maternal uncles who topped them in anal intercourse for
six years.
So they bang him in the ass for six years.
The nearby Jack Jack.
Why try refers to the adult penetrator as the moe?
He Anus father is what it means.
And the receiving child as the MOH Mog anus son Jesus fucking Christ.
What sizes on playgirl.com or on one [inaudible].
This is a letter to the editor or something.
Oh,
this is a big,
this is,
this is a,
um,
a study on these people in New Guinea.
This is crazy.
It was by an anthropologist of Gilbert hurt.
Uh,
the editor of ritualized homosexuality in Melanesia.
Do you know,
like Afghanistan,
they have like a day of gayness where you're allowed to have gay sex.
I think it's like every third hole.
Every day there's a lot of gain is going.
It's accepted well,
there's a lot fun gave,
stays
in the cave.
Well,
there's a lot of that.
Um,
you know,
that weird thing that goes on in some of those ancient tribes where you,
you only go to the women for,
for intercourse,
for,
you know,
for making babies.
That was boys and for pleasure.
Ancient Greek police will,
they did this.
A lot of cultures went down that road.
It's really interesting when you stop and think about how many cultures went
gay.
It's like,
what was it a lack of understanding?
Was that,
I mean w w what is it that led everybody to go get it?
Was it more natural?
Is it,
where are we more restricted now in our behaviors because we have too much
access to information that's more advanced than as does that.
What is,
how would they,
how would they tricking everybody in the bone and I mean it's gay.
People must be so mad that like back then God damn everybody was gay.
I think they've shown that there is a biological advantage for the species for a
certain portion of people to be gay.
It's kind of like some kind of for decorating.
Ah,
no,
I think it's just for,
just for flavor.
I don't know exactly what it is,
but I don't think bring a certain whole entire culture to turn that way.
I don't think there's been really a good amount of understanding on that as far
as,
because I've studied ancient Greece quite,
you know,
quite a lot and Rome was funny to Rome.
If you took it in the ass,
you are,
you are what's called a faggot.
There was a slur that was called like a Faggot,
basically did the apprentice.
That was a slur if you took it,
but if you gave it whatever that sells how it is in Mexico,
no big deal.
Yeah.
I mean that's kind of,
I guess what it's what it's like in prison as well.
Now is it to a certain code?
I think that's what I,
that's what I've,
uh,
I've heard for some inmates it whatever.
But if you take it,
oh fuck yeah,
that's not good.
But yeah.
I don't know.
Uh,
I don't know what if you're a prisoner in New Guinea,
they're straight trying to get big inch throat.
Come on.
Who wants to fuck me straight as fuck,
I'm on month.
Who wants to fuck me?
I'm trying to get big and strong.
I will take in so much semen.
I will break down these walls.
They cannot stop me.
Imagine if that really works.
If you shoot loads in the guys asking me becomes a hulk,
can imagine,
it's like just a certain amount.
Like you can just keep pumping loads in there.
It's not like you can't back off.
It's not like,
you know,
uh Oh I tried to do a trend,
transcendental meditation,
but it got boring after the first hour.
No,
you've got to really get into it for months and months and months before you
really achieve any sort of success.
But if one guy is just taking loads in the ass all day,
like a factory line and there's a scientific study that has shown that if your
body and Jess a certain amount of semen,
it realizes that it's continually getting raped.
So it grows ridiculously strong to fight off the attacker as long as your body
is alive.
It's like your body produces super steroids and this is like a new study that
they find.
So one guy just fucking volunteers to take one for the team as a scientific
adventure and they,
they,
they shackle him into a fucking thing and it's just like in Captain America,
we blows up,
he gets all huge.
This guy has just taken dick in the ass all day and after the first month is
just tired and he wants to quit and they're like,
hang in there.
But I think we think we are recent McNulty would be talking to them on the
recent tests have shown success.
We need a couple more days out of your kid.
You do it for America.
I think that there'd be people wearing a button that you got here.
Sure.
And then the aliens maybe.
Maybe four minute.
You love gay humor,
man.
It's so funny.
Like everything is [inaudible] if you get tricked into doing gay.
It's so funny though.
I love when gay people trick people into Intersex.
I got a I if you've ever been propositioned by guy,
uh,
not,
not seriously.
Like never where I was like,
all right.
It was more jokingly propositioned by gay comic was we thought he was being
cute.
It was really uncomfortable.
It wouldn't,
I wouldn't say his name.
Say his name.
He's a loser.
Is that right away is calling for,
I don't even know his name anymore.
I really wouldn't know his name,
but he was a really like aggressive with it.
I was like,
come on dude,
you know,
not gay.
Stop.
It stuck in.
Then I had to go,
dude,
get the fuck outta here.
You creepy cont like this is,
this is like what a woman feels like when some guy wants to fuck.
I'm like,
Yo,
how gross.
And I was like,
how dare you think he could fuck me.
Even if I did go get silly bitch.
Yeah.
That's more like you wouldn't have to so high.
I mean if someone like if I'm going to give up my ass for the first time,
I was going to be like Elton John.
You know what I'm saying?
George Michael's or something,
man,
I want to go with someone famous and game with a lot of,
a lot of power that like talked me into it.
I don't want to some shit comedian,
they can't even open for me.
I wouldn't even take you with me on the road and you're going to fuck me out.
Dare you.
All right Brian.
Yeah.
That was a,
that I think that was,
that was the main aphrodisiac in ancient Greece was not necessarily physical
appearance,
but like,
uh,
like Socrates for example,
ugly mother Fucker,
but he fucked everybody had a lot of gay sex.
Right.
And you have a lot of games,
a lot tons.
Everybody wanted to fuck soccer cause you're so brilliant.
It'd be funny like that was,
that was what a,
that's what got him going.
That was on,
it was a government mandate.
The Dad be included on every Socrates quote that you put on Twitter.
By the way,
he had tons of gay sex.
So like Socrates is super wise.
What the soul and the spirit and the transcended journey.
And then underneath that Socrates,
by the way,
he had tons of gay sex.
Tons.
Oh,
gay sex and caught me pink.
He's
gay.
But sex.
Yeah.
All of those people,
even the most incredible warrior leaders like Alexander the great conquered the
known world at 25 also had a lot of times about sex.
Right?
He was a great leader.
By the way.
I've been reading some of Pressfield's work and I'm talking about him.
Some of his research,
some of his stories on leadership are pretty,
pretty epic.
Like for example,
at some point they were deep and into India and the troops were fucking tired
and pissed off.
They're getting mosquito bit and they're in swamps and they're fighting
elephants and it's terrifying and it sucks and they are about to mutiny.
And so Alexander who always led from the front on his horse be selfless with
this,
you know,
big red plume on his helmet and had been at the forefront of every one of these
scuffles just starts taking off all his armor and strips like completely down to
nothing.
And he shows all the scars on his body.
He says,
who amongst you has more scars than me?
That man comes forward and I'll take you home.
And everybody looks at each other and they realized nobody had and they started
cheering.
They're like,
we're going to follow you to the end of the world was that never happened
though.
So passwords wrote it later.
That was the real problem with history,
man.
Right.
Something that someone said really cool.
Meanwhile they were like a little funny.
He had to fucking done some crazy shit.
Pushes troops that far.
Unquestionably.
But you know when you attribute quotes to someone from that far back,
like good luck with chat history.
Yeah.
You know how that goes,
but some good stories about me that weren't true.
You know,
you ever,
you ever talked to someone from high school and they go,
oh remember that time he did that?
You broken into the firehouse and you set everything on fire on you.
Like what are you talking about?
I didn't do anything like that.
Oh come you don't remember that person was the person who probably been telling
the story about you,
how you set a fucking house on fire or something,
you know?
I mean,
any makeup,
fill in the blank with whatever the fuck craziness.
The weird stuff with history is being reported in ancient China.
Some of the histories get really fucked up cause you couldn't tell the emperor
when he was doing something wrong.
Dot.
You'd get killed.
So what they used to do is they used to tell histories of weird things happening
in nature,
like wheat.
And this day we saw the geese flying backwards.
And that's what they would say to the emperor because he was the center of the
universe.
So when he was fucking up,
the universe would start fucking up.
So that was their way,
telling the emperor that he was doing something wrong.
As it was like this day a horse gave birth to a pig and the emperor would be
like,
hmm,
I must be doing something wrong.
Really,
if horses are giving birth to pigs,
so you have these influence the emperor,
that's how they influenced the emperor.
So they've got like two cocky,
did they ever get too cocky?
The fact stupid pig led the empire in the wrong direction.
But there's this bitch that mother for being so obvious.
Yeah,
hack was the game game.
You had to phone man abide by that.
So definitely dragged that pitch.
You don't have to work on your storylines.
That's craziness with him.
So then I guess to finish off this,
uh,
finish off this trip here.
So,
um,
how do you remember all this?
It was incredibly lucid.
Try to video notes or audio notes or anything.
I wrote it down after I was done,
but you know,
here's the,
here's the deal.
That's really something like you do Iowasca right?
You started at night,
you know,
you take it maybe eight o'clock,
it's usually around dusk.
It seems to be kind of consistent.
You never take it like right in the noon,
you know,
it's very rare that you'll do a day ceremony.
So you do it at night and so you go through and you finish around three o'clock
cause I have WASC uh,
you know,
gets out of your system by about eight hours and it's this very dreamlike,
magical experience.
And then you go to sleep and have a very dream like dream experience.
So you wake up already and you're like,
weird.
That was weird,
you know.
But at Boga you're up for so fucking long.
Are you eating at all?
You can hardly eat.
It's like being under an intense stimulants.
So you're like barely like sipping like a tiny bit of water to keep your mouth,
you know,
keep your mouth horrible.
Yeah.
Cause everybody ever died of dehydration or he's,
he's been a 10th generation Shalman and no one's died and his whole fuck down
there too.
His whole thing swat along.
It's not too bad.
Not too bad.
It's the kind of the,
it's a good time of year though,
I guess to be out there in Costa Rica.
But does he have summertime ones when you go crazy apocalyptic now Martin Sheen
in the hotel room,
you remember that shit.
Here's your wet sponge to wipe your head with mean the we call from it is is I
guess if you go too deep,
you can't recall anything like Graham Hancock in his report.
He has a lot of the same start but then at a certain point he blacked out
because you just went to like the vibrations and whatever happened,
got too intense where he didn't remember it.
Well,
whatever.
My dose was allowed me to maintain a pretty lucid consciousness.
And then the fact that I didn't go to sleep for like 30 hours after I took it,
I got to really think about it and let it set in and there was no confusion with
having to go to sleep.
So that's why I was able to recall all of these things and you know,
kind of great detail.
You also,
they encourage you to bring a voice recorder,
which I remember,
you know,
mumbled some random things,
but I ended up remembering,
you know,
pretty much what I mumbled anyways into that wow.
Voice recorder.
But,
um,
do you have a voice activated one or just picked it up?
No,
you don't have to.
That would have been cool as some technology that I would highly recommend.
I didn't even know that existed,
but can do had those forever.
That's sweet.
If you,
if anybody decides to go do this,
I would recommend that because it does get tough to remember stuff and you
can't,
right.
I mean,
trying to look at a page or a screen with your eyes.
It just forget about it.
Your eyes are fucking blowing out any sounds at all.
Were you just laying there or we'd like moaning?
No,
no,
I wasn't.
I was,
I make a habit of not trying to moan.
Yeah.
That's the moment experience.
The beginning of love to love you baby.
But,
uh,
well it sounds like can you can talk so you can talk to the,
a Chaman encourages you to talk openly if you want.
And there was some times where I'd go to ask them questions,
but the moment you form a question,
you get the answer.
So it was funny,
it became like a funny thing.
Like I would ask them like,
what,
how long,
you know,
blah,
Blah till I'm able to do it.
And the,
I would get the answer and be like,
oh,
that'll be about five or six hours.
And I would just kind of laugh because I was getting my questions answered by
the [inaudible] I did.
You asked about alien.
I asked about aliens.
And this gets really kind of,
this gets really weird here when we're asking about aliens.
So,
so I asked,
I asked about aliens.
I was like,
what's,
you know,
what's going on with aliens?
And um,
basically what they had told me is that aliens have been,
had a direct interest in the fostering and development of life on earth and
bringing us to a point of sentience.
Um,
and they've had an active role in that.
But the reason that they've been doing that is not too much to affect our
physical bodies or effect our minds.
But this is where it gets weird.
And I'm going to couch the saying,
this is just a theory.
I don't know if I like,
I'm not going to assign by psychedelic trip and balls and you get this idea and
you run with it.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
so what they're doing is they're,
they're tweaking our DNA to allow a different type of soul,
the more advanced soul to allow to enter the human body and be able to direct
our decisions.
So basically they're saying like there's different types of souls that can
access certain DNA.
So like a chimp DNA,
like a chimp,
like a human soul.
Once it's been human,
you can never go back to chimp because just what the chimp is able to do,
what he's able to think about,
the soldiers wouldn't fit in that DNA life form.
Right?
But there's other souls more advanced than humans,
right?
So they've been modifying slightly the DNA of humans to allow these more
advanced souls to be able to enter these human bodies.
And that's,
that was like,
I was,
I was not expecting that at all.
And that's what it was just like boom,
just straight up told me,
I was like,
really?
It's like really bitch.
Like this is what's going on there.
Allowing,
you know,
that different access to a whole new level of souls to help take us to the point
where we can not blow ourselves up and create,
you know,
fully sentience being,
did they express it?
This would be an evolutionary thing or a progressive thing or would it just be,
they would come down and metal spaceships and been doing it is what is what the
men,
do you feel you have an advanced soul?
Yes or no?
You know,
I mean there was,
I do feel like I have some,
you know,
some advantages that,
that or that I feel very blessed to have.
You know,
I feel like I can handle the psychedelic experience very well and I think that's
certainly,
you know,
I don't give myself credit for that.
Like I kicked ass and that's why I got,
I think I was something that was innate and I was blessed to have.
So you think you are blessed to be good at taking psychedelics?
I think the way that I think the w the way that I can get information from it,
I feel like,
you know,
if I have one,
one innate talent,
you know,
and in this arena,
that would be it.
I don't think I'm any genius or how many,
you know,
magical.
He was a thoughtful guy.
I think a thoughtful person who has an intense experience is going to be able to
withdraw something from it.
Why would you have that?
And also you've got your mind and your,
your eyes on progress.
You,
you were trying to improve as a human being as well.
One of the most important things for everybody when,
when people get old and they fall apart,
one of the reasons why they really fall apart is because they don't have
anything to try to do anymore than any of the thing they're trying to accomplish
it.
Even though they don't have a passion anymore.
It's true.
There's things that stimulate you.
[inaudible] you know,
whatever it is.
We are craftsmen or uh,
you know,
I went to visit this guy that makes a pool cues when I was in Chicago was got
Joe Gold and uh,
he's uh,
he's makes us pull cute.
It's very famous called the cognizant and it's one of the most sought after cues
in the world.
Cause he was like a really high level player when he was younger too.
And this dude's,
you know,
he's in his sixties,
he smokes like fucking three packs of cigarettes a day.
You know,
he's not eating healthy.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he'll tell you like,
you talked to them about a cancer and he's like,
Hey,
get it.
You don't get it.
I'm not going to get it.
You know,
like some people can just smoke cigarettes.
You don't get it.
That's heavy Chicago accent.
But this dude,
like you talked to him about his cues and you know like you could like you see
the passion in what he does,
like the,
the,
the pride that he has for what he's created.
That,
you know,
the,
this is a very few people that are like known in the world to make great
instruments in,
in any sort of a,
whether it's musical insurance or a game tool,
like a pool cue or something like that.
And when there's a guy who was like a real master craftsmen,
but the one thing that you find inevitably always and all these guys is this
passion for what they do.
Totally.
You know,
this,
this desire to create something that they really feel proud of.
You know,
the,
the creative force inside of us is the most,
the thing that gives you the most happiness,
the things that give you the,
the biggest feeling of reward.
You know,
like this.
I mean this is not,
it doesn't seem like it's creative cause it's kind of just this free full fuck
fest,
this podcast that we do.
But this is the most rewarding thing that either me or Brian,
I think he's ever done.
Have you done anything that's more rewarding than this now
except close together?
I don't think it works that way.
So rewarding.
Yeah,
it's,
I again,
I agree with that,
but you know,
what is it?
It's because you're putting out a lot of creativity.
You're putting on a lot of stuff.
Like people are getting something out of it and the more you put out,
the more people get out of it and then it becomes like a super rewarding like
happy,
good feeling thing
keeps you out while you're creating a positive feedback loop.
Exactly.
Which is really cool.
And even some everybody getting the cues,
you know,
you create a masterful piece.
Every time someone strikes the ball with that que you're creating this positive
feedback loop,
which is some people don't have anything new like doing.
That's just really what,
what's fucked up?
Is it true that we need a queen?
And we also need workers.
Is it,
do we have worker be humans that are just out there just fucking barely,
barely able to figure out how to like walk to the car,
hit the button?
No,
but do I really,
I think they're,
I think there are certain people who have,
you know,
different gifts than other people.
Maybe different proclivities,
different talents.
You know,
I don't think the talent level is the same,
but I think even if it's the most menial tasks,
you can do that task with your eye on,
with your eye on something else.
The trash man can have it be a trash man with the idea that,
you know,
this must happen for society to function and be good and this has to happen.
Or we'll have like France was during the riots and fucking garbage everywhere.
Like I am doing my part in that.
But meanwhile their eye is on a different prize.
Maybe they want to master,
you know,
whatever else it is.
There's very little crafts and things.
Everything's kind of mass produced.
So that's tough too because some of these people,
some of these trashman might've been great fucking blacksmiths or something like
that.
But those skills,
yeah.
You know,
it's very hard to make something or do something.
So they put themselves into Budweiser and football or whatever and they're super
kind of not happy.
So it's a challenging time.
[inaudible] horseshoe stupid.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
There's not those kind of skills.
And that would be super rewarding to make like a sword.
There are now four shoe,
even to this day,
you're hammering something.
There's fire or watched this special job on um,
one of the history channel or something like that.
It was a thing with mark to Costco.
You remember that guy?
He was a martial arts guy from it did a bunch of movies,
like a Capoeira movie,
a bunch of things.
Was He,
um,
he went to Japan
and went to Wa,
it was,
a lot of,
it was on Musashi and a lot of it was also on the construction of the Samurai
swords.
And they went to this dude who still make Samurai swords the old way and they
were hammering this whole deal and folding it.
Oh,
it's fucking bad ass,
man.
It makes you want to see a Samurai movie.
Like,
come on bitch.
You know,
they're hammering your train.
I mean,
and then they show the blade after this guy's done with countless hours of
perfecting this and slicing it into water when it's red hot and,
and hammering on it.
I mean,
it's fucking an amazing craft.
You know,
the,
the creation of Samurai swords that afterwards the blade,
you see the etchings than the line looks like would grab on it.
It's been folded so many times.
What people don't understand is they flatten out a piece of steel and then they
folded over the heat it up and they slam it together somehow with a hammer.
And then they keep doing that over and over and over and over and over.
And it makes sense go insanely strong steel,
just insanely strong.
And then after this guy does that,
he steps outside and chops this,
uh,
this bamboo stock and half.
It's so fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
That's just so bad ass oh comic to Tom People.
It's so nice that people still know how that guy does that.
It's so important because that's got to go away,
right?
I mean,
we,
we're,
we're lucky that we have a window into the Japanese Samurai Sword.
Make totally,
you know,
because that,
that could easily a hundred years from now,
that could be like dust in the wind.
You know,
nobody knows how to do it anymore.
You can't watch it anymore.
There's no video.
You know,
we lost it all.
It's all,
it's all on DVDs and now everything's in the clouds and so there's no more
Samurai shit.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
we could,
we could forget that,
that critical part of history where people have figured out this insane,
you know,
way to construct a sword.
Yeah.
Those sorts,
I've actually been looking at some of the,
some of them go for,
they're called knee Honcho.
The blades that are authentic made by Japanese craftsmen signed on the bottom
underneath.
Then they'll go for like a hundred grand,
a hundred grand.
You look up in the Honcho blades and she's like,
that.
There's some,
actually there's some pretty good us sword makers apparently doing stuff.
One guy named Howard Clark making some pretty cool swords.
Really?
There's actually polishers too.
So if you're going to buy a store that's custom made,
he spent like 5,000 for the blade and then you can spend like 3,500 on jump do
just polishing it,
giving it that,
you know that uh,
I forget what it's called,
but on the blade,
that kind of mirror frosting that looks like the uh,
it looks like how it is and you'll spend 3,500 just getting it properly.
The Ham on,
they call h and you get 3,500 getting it polished and then you get it mounted.
You put the suit on,
you wrap it up,
you do all the things that you're,
you know,
handmade sword.
You're still in it for about 10 grand these many years.
Was it where people just fought with swords?
How many years was that before they figured out like arrows and then arrows were
pretty early before they figured out swords had to come before ours.
You know,
you think clubs with spikes and shit.
Yes,
but swords and spears,
Spears Beers were around pretty early,
but arrows,
arrows were around pretty fucking bad cause they had slings,
so they had that concept of that sling.
The slings here was the one of the first ones where you put the spear and the
little notch.
Yeah,
it's like a man,
a handle thing in the momentum kind of hawks it.
Then figuring out the arrows from there,
but the motto amazing that they figured that out.
That was caveman fucking figured that out.
That was pretty cool.
Then the Mongols were the ones who really advanced the boat because the English,
both the Longbow was nowhere near the range of the Mongol recurve bow.
Real Mongols were the ones that invented the recurve bow and that gave them some
insane range,
smaller bow and the way that it's bent back double allowed them to have way out,
shoot the other archer's,
which is one of the technological advancements that allowed them to conquer so
they know that they would come up with some Ted Nugent type shit in the future.
You know I have a compound bone of rubber pig and I shoot that fucker my
backyard sometimes.
God Damn,
those arrows go fast.
They do.
That's,
I got a 60 pound pull one cause I'm fucking man.
Shit.
I'll check that shit out there.
But um,
did the arrows fly off that ball man,
it's scary.
You know there like some serious projectiles.
You remember Bo and Luke Duke,
they had to use bows and arrows because they were felons and they weren't
allowed to have guns with that and the dukes of Hazzard rails,
that's why they had boats.
That's how I first found out about compound bows.
Watching the Dukes of hazard.
You have one in few,
you have one of those.
Do you have one of the new ones?
So it's like really small shit.
There are some that were long.
They look like regular bows,
but now they've like compressed them.
It's not very big.
It's not like that's one of the new ones,
like an English or anything.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
The newer ones are smaller because Amazon Bose,
they're like fucking nine feet long.
Yeah.
Or the old Japanese bows.
It's like a giant piece of bamboo.
Yes.
Do you ever seen that photo of a,
there's people flying over in a plane.
There's a tribe and they got their arrows pointed,
uh,
at the,
cameras now.
I have never seen it.
I've seen that picture.
Apparently it's fake,
but it was super bummed.
Like,
cause it was like an outlet.
Yeah,
it was a,
a,
you know,
a tribe,
a undiscovered tribe found.
They're like [inaudible] going to exactly flying and point your email.
They just dressed all these assholes off and put fucking red paint on them and
shit.
And they made him look really crazy.
Like the cover their whole body in red paint.
And one of them was like all blue.
You know,
it was pretty nutty.
When you were talking about earlier about the vision that you had about stars
exploding and shit like that.
I asked Brian to pull this video up,
Neil Tyson,
cause it's one of the most Badass and inspirational things.
It's a Neil degrasse Tyson if you've never heard of them.
It's just really fucking cool guy who is not just uh,
an astrophysicist.
What,
what is his,
his exact credentials,
whatever it is.
He's a super genius,
fucking astro physicists,
astrophysicists.
But what he's really,
he also is,
is a great personality and the way he explains things,
she's like a really,
really likable guy.
And the way he explains things is so smooth and so brilliant that,
you know,
it really like makes you absorb these,
these ideas and these images because you'll like him so much because he seemed
like such a likable guy.
And He,
uh,
had this one that,
was somebody tweeted it to me and it's something that I knew,
but it's something that when you hear it again,
especially hearing it from him makes it sound so crazy when you think about how,
what is the most human is constructed tomato you can share with us about the
universe.
The most astounding fact,
the most astounding fact is the knowledge
that the atoms that comprise life on earth,
the atoms that make up the human body are traceable to the crucibles that cooked
light elements into heavy elements in their core under extreme temperatures and
pressures.
These stars,
the high mass ones among them,
when unstable in their later years,
they collapsed and then exploded,
scattering their enriched guts across the galaxy.
Guts made of carbon,
nitrogen,
oxygen,
and all the fundamental ingredients of life itself.
These ingredients become part of gas clouds that condense,
collapse,
form the next generation of solar systems,
stars with orbiting planets.
And those planets now have ingredients for life.
So,
so that when I look up at the night sky and I know that yes,
we are part of this universe,
we are in this universe,
but perhaps more important than both of those facts is that the universe is in
us.
When I reflect on that fact,
I look up,
many people feel small cause they're small and the universe is big.
But I feel big
because my atoms came from those stars.
There's a level of connectivity that's really what you want in life.
You want to feel connected.
I want to feel relevant.
What a few like
your participant,
the goings on of activities and events around you.
That's precisely what we are just by being alive.
Hm.
God Damn.
That dude's a bad mother fucker.
Yeah,
yes.
That's amazing that I came off a question to.
Beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
He does have left and right all day.
That's what he does.
Go on the Internet and Neil degrasse Tyson all day.
He's got just all these amazing videos of him breaking down things in such an
entertaining way.
I mean,
and he's such a nice guy.
He was even on Bill Maher show and he was in debating with some guy from GM was
trying to say that climate change is not manmade.
And,
and,
and he was like really being polite about when the guy was like talking about
the science behind.
He was like,
that's not true.
Like,
well,
he was really being very nice and he shut the guy down like a master fighter
when he spars with an he doesn't shine.
Yeah,
he was Bobby pizza man,
this guy's a fucking,
uh,
a gigantic corporate,
you know,
a monster,
a guy who's a in charge of a huge company that probably does a fuck load of
polluting the environment and doesn't want anything to change as far as
regulations,
concerns.
So he's spouting out a bunch of bullshit.
And a genius,
you know,
but the idea that we are actually made of stardust,
I had such a fuck.
It's such a complete mind.
Fuck it is.
You know,
it's such a
what?
Wrapping your head around that.
Fuck.
Yeah.
You asked in La,
you accidentally said the,
you know,
an interesting term that directed Panspermia,
which was also a theory of a,
of Francis Crick.
Basically what he was saying is that the DNA,
that the life forms are so complex that a lot of the Bible,
a lot of science right now talks about this like prebiotic soup of all of these
molecules kind of just rummaging around all crazy,
bumping into each other,
eventually creating proteins.
Well,
some of these proteins are like 200 atoms long and,
and the probability of even one of these proteins in life is comprised of many
proteins.
Remember to create one of these specific proteins necessary for life.
The odds of that happening at random,
our one over the,
over the number one with 260 zeros after it won over one with 260 zeroes.
That's the,
just the pure probability of those atoms bumping together for primordial.
So we can't even fathom a number like that.
I mean it goes across the room.
So that's the probabilities of life,
of,
of just one protein.
And then you got to figure these proteins have to come together and create,
you know,
and bump into each other and then form these complex proteins where they're
working together to create life.
So that's why,
you know,
Francis Crick was an esoteric,
didn't really believe in God,
but he couldn't wrap his head around the statistical improbability that had
happened like that.
That's why he came up with the theory of directed panspermia either his theory
was that directed actual beings,
his theory was that being seeded the planet Francis Crick,
that's what he believed.
Really.
He believed that being seated at now another Panspermia cheery this,
this was in Graham Hancock's and it's pretty well,
pretty well referenced to,
I went and checked some of the references that he had,
but um,
but another theory was that the comments,
and this is non-directed Panspermia the comments delivered this bacteria,
but it's a really interesting thought.
I mean,
there were saying basically the chances of this happening was like a hurricane
assembling a seven 37 in a junkyard.
That was the chances of life for me.
Life on earth,
life on earth,
a hurricane,
assembling a seven 37 in a junk yard,
just a junk yard.
And then boom,
the wind goes,
oh shit,
there's a plane.
Holy Fuck.
What's really amazing is that we had a complete reboot 65 million years ago.
Yeah.
That the most amazing thing about earth today is it 65 million years ago,
none of this shit was around 65 million years ago.
We got hit by a giant
rock that killed off all the dinosaurs and you know,
left a huge fucking crater in the Yucatan.
And from that,
everything has got to this point,
just 65 million years.
Imagine if the earth was only 65 million years old.
I mean,
it's a really an incredible amount of time.
Don't get me wrong,
but it has nothing on 4.6 billion was the earth really is or whatever it is.
So if you wanted to see the planet and have it actually work,
you know,
let's just go along with,
with cricks theory that it was some Intel,
it directed Panspermia you just find the toughest little bastard of life form,
which is bacteria and then just let natural selection work.
You just splashed that on there.
And then from there you realize that the forces at work of natural selection are
going to create myriad lifeforms that are going to be optimal for living in
whatever climate develops.
And so I think that was his theory that has just had to have come from somewhere
else.
But then you run into the fucking problem of,
you know,
the chicken and the egg.
Some point at some point some primordial soup had to form the first life.
So it doesn't really get you around the problem to begin with.
He's just saying that on earth there wasn't enough time for that to have been
for this to have been the first one.
I imagine if that's what the,
uh,
the asteroid 65 million years ago was like a correction.
Like,
look,
there's nothing is ever going to get done.
We have giant fucking lizard on the wrong way.
Somehow under the old giant predatory lizards with a softball sized brains.
Bigger and bigger.
Yeah.
They eat everything.
You can't.
You can't even grow past like a mole.
You're like a little mole running around in the dirt,
hiding from giant feet.
What a shit bag life.
It must have been back then when the dinosaurs were fucking roaming everywhere.
You imagine everywhere you look,
dinosaurs,
t rex,
wandering around your neighborhood and it was either by chance or by some
intelligence.
That's what it is.
They just control.
They just control z.
That bitch,
nope,
let's try it out and do it again.
Do and went back a few steps.
Let's do a rag wipe.
The hard drive.
Yeah.
Kill off everything.
Everything bigger than a chicken's got to go.
What do you think was like the biggest thing that lit a lot of birds apparently
and so crocodiles and stuff like that.
Red Ocean stuff.
There's some stuff.
Yeah.
Stuff.
Yeah,
but like Sila cancer,
shit like that.
It's Wa much longer.
Yeah,
they were super old.
Yeah.
They still have like appendages,
like the,
the,
the transitionary fossil between like walking and swimming that the Christians
are over screaming for.
Where's your transitionary fossils?
You tell me.
You tell me that the Lord created me out of a monkey.
See Monkey still.
They're still around.
That is a true thing,
man.
Imagine monkeys.
Like,
how the fuck did these assholes figure it out?
Like monkeys were monkeys,
you know,
million years ago,
2 million years ago.
There was the sane,
not us.
We figured some shit out and rocketed,
passed all those bitches or alien intervention or we go,
Francis Crick says,
Yep.
Are we got help?
It's a,
it's an interesting theory.
You know,
it's tough.
I mean maybe shit,
maybe tough.
We'll get bad enough in our,
in our lifetime that we'll find definitively.
You know that the fucking,
the Oz behind the curtain is just
going to have to say,
all right bitches,
I'm here for reals.
You guys are blowing it.
But I think that's,
it doesn't seem like that's there.
It seems like if they are there,
they're trying to avoid that at all.
Fucking costs,
but I don't know.
I think maybe if shit got fucking total Armageddon enough,
you know,
maybe it'd be like,
all right,
you guys are going to kill each other.
We've been waiting for this for four and a half billion years,
so here's the plan.
You know,
don't you tell me that?
Was that clear?
You know?
Yeah.
Dad did that.
So it probably would psychedelics,
are there tools,
tools to try to get through this?
Absolutely.
I mean,
all of them seem to be about self reflection.
All of them seem to offer besides good times and besides using them as a
recreation,
and a lot of people say,
man,
you shouldn't use psychedelics as a recreation.
They're very intense and powerful medicine to which I reply,
yeah,
but they're fun and recreation,
so yes,
you should fuck you.
You're so serious.
Like people get so serious psychedelic drugs,
man or not to be taken for recreation.
They are important learning tools or they're great to take a little bit and
giggle.
Guess what?
That's good too.
You can't tell me it's bad.
If I ate a little bit of mushrooms and laugh my ass off,
that's not bad.
You know,
you can't tell me I'm abusing it,
the fuck them abusing it.
I'm so happy.
I've got some mushrooms and it made me laugh.
Made a movie better,
made a conversation better.
It's important to demystify him to a certain degree.
I mean there are certain settings where you should take them seriously.
Like don't fucking take a Bogo Willy Nilly with your buddies.
Like that's a nightmare.
You're just,
you're setting yourself up for a bad situation.
But at the same time,
you know it's not magic.
You know,
there are plants that are here designed,
I believe is tools.
Like you said,
they're part of what should be in everybody's tool bag,
which was able to die.
Man.
It's obvious.
I mean there's a reason why bees pollinate flowers,
you know,
there's a,
there's a reason why this whole thing goes down.
They make honey create hives and it's all,
that's what they do.
It's what they've always done.
There's clearly some sort of a system in place and I think that all of these
plants are a part of this system and they're all aiding us all these psychedelic
experiences over there to show us different experiences,
different perspectives and aid us along the way there.
Self-Improvement devices and I think the,
you know,
kind of the making them forbid and both by the church and by the state because
the church has done a hell of a lot of damage to making and they're behind a lot
of these,
you know,
kind of destruction on the last thing they want is people high making up their
own religions.
Right,
exactly.
Having direct access without having to go through them,
it takes away their power base.
So that I think is the main factor.
That's really retarded.
Our growth as,
as humanity and in what's put us in this situation where,
you know,
we're pretty out of touch in general now that not everybody,
certainly there's a whole wave of consciousness that we're seeing developed.
But having that absent for so many years,
these puritans and pilgrims and all of this,
you know,
religious bullshit and Islam and everything,
if they were able to really get back to the truth,
they've eliminated the access to self correction.
You know,
there's been like,
all right,
we got this bullshit path and what's going to stop us?
What's going to stop this juggernaut?
Well,
truth and self correction.
how do find that while all the
psychedelics boom done make a mil legal,
you know that the,
uh,
the Supreme Court upheld the churches use of a eyewash SCA in New Mexico.
You know about all that,
that whole situation,
right?
Yeah.
2006,
you know,
they're still doing it.
There's a,
apparently there's a church that you can go to.
It's a Oh,
Centro,
a spirit,
a bed,
a fishy NTA,
une out dough,
veggie towel,
and we're here.
Maybe I'll dove vegetal the vegetables.
Like the idea is that the vegetable,
you're drinking their drink and IOWASCA and it's a part of their,
their church,
they're allowed to drink it by the fucking supreme court.
They,
they treat it as a true religious sacrament because they're a Christian Church,
even though it's a schedule one substance.
So they're,
they're allowed to do it.
We just got to get that church to really fucking kick ass and expand the roots.
And maybe that's,
maybe that's the way I might be the way yet.
I mean,
they already got their fucking green light.
You know,
it's a small congregation right now in New Mexico.
I'm sure that they'd be interested in branching out,
forming,
forming some affiliates.
Yeah.
Maybe that's what we should hop on on it,
on it.
Audit Maboga labs and vegetal image tile and DMT labs.
Yeah.
On it.
Um,
uh,
IOWASCA spiritual centers.
You Imagine Jesus Christ.
Imagine that actually became a real thing.
And that's something we got into.
Whoa,
that's a,
that's a way to really have an impact on society.
It's really too bad you can't do that or even think about doing it.
Now,
one of my questions was,
all right,
what,
what should society do to self correct?
And I got two answers and one of the answers was,
you know,
you're doing one of them now.
You know,
this is one of the tools to show you truth.
This is going to take people back.
It's going to eliminate their addictions,
all the things that are fucked up about themselves,
you know,
self correct them.
And then by self correcting themselves,
it's gonna self correct society as a whole.
This is a great way back.
But then the other thing it said was,
which was pretty funny and it and more humorous than anything,
but it just said,
it showed me a picture of congress and everybody just being completely naked,
like no clothes,
no nothing.
And it was like,
you know,
people are hiding so much,
even behind the very clothes that we're wearing,
you know,
that's just allowing them to be this different person.
You know,
this transparency that would be around if we lived,
you know,
kind of tribally it,
it's almost like the symbolism of wearing these suits in allows,
you know,
Newt Gingrich to be all suited up and he would be a person you would never
fucking listen to.
[inaudible]
his body naked and he's just being all gnarly and nasty and his normal newt cell
naked people will be like,
come on man.
But you know,
it just allows this kind of falsehood to covering up as disgusting body.
But does that,
does that preclude someone from having a great and brilliant idea if they would
discuss?
No,
I don't think so.
If Michael Moore was,
I think you had translated him at protests when you try and send it,
I think people would be like,
that's a brilliant fucking,
cause everybody would see everybody naked.
So you got used to the whole gamut,
be like go on and do a one of those nude beaches,
which is mostly the worst,
you know,
physically a terrible sites.
You terribly.
But you know,
at a certain point you just look past it and like,
oh these people are cool,
cool people start getting creepy witch.
Right?
Yeah.
I could have it to it.
That's like,
yeah,
I think Congress should totally be naked.
That's exactly what they should do.
They should make those fucks come out there naked and say,
listen,
look,
it totally makes sense.
You know,
you,
I should want,
I don't want to see you.
I don't want to look.
Imagine if you take the clothes off as Nazi swastikas,
you shit.
And like there's a tattooed dick goes here with straight up their ass.
You can imagine you find that all kinds of nutty shit about these people that
are in Congress,
but the idea that I'm being completely naked is a great idea because they would,
they would feel vulnerable.
They would,
they would be less likely to,
uh,
to feel strong and empowered and willing to do crazy shit and on behalf of their
special interest groups that have got him into office.
Yeah.
You know,
and I'm more likely to face the wrath of America.
Yeah.
Looking at your saggy tents,
some crazy bills,
man.
Ted solemnly and all of this crazy,
you know,
there's so much that comes from these frustrations that people have,
maybe they have a fucking,
you know,
they're not confident sexually and they get,
kind of rejected by women and they get all worked up.
Well,
what do they do?
They seek power ruthlessly,
you know,
and find this kind of position where they can wheel,
wield this power over people and demand their affections and we have no evidence
of their enlightenment,
you know?
Yup.
So I mean that was,
that was a bit humorous but there was some truth to it and,
and certainly how,
you know,
people are just not fucking transparent.
You know,
it's,
it's worth being led and all of these people,
you know,
to use my first analogy of what the bogus said they are being run purely as the
mind boy part of themselves,
that juvenile brain centric part that's just fucking crank and shit out with no
kind of real connection to the eternal into,
to all of us as you know,
robust human beings.
And the idea that somehow just because things are written down,
written down on paper and that they'd been lived this way for x amount of years,
that that makes all this nonsense and this ridiculous pageantry that goes on in
our government,
that that makes it normal and it makes it real.
Makes it okay.
It's become a game.
And what apps are,
I'm in the middle of coffin
and it for sure game people find ways to circumvent the game is exactly what it
is.
Yeah.
And then they ended up just playing a game.
They've lost touch with what it was really meant to be a democracy to help lead
people to an optimal life.
They are gentlemen will yield the floor and a gentleman will yield the floor.
The fuck are you?
What kind of ridiculous rules are you calling out and filibusters and things.
I mean people read that nonsense.
This is what we're preaching here on the Joe Rogan experience.
Which preaching and Internet based government ceiling.
What to do it.
No more representative kind of no representative government?
No,
no,
no congressmen or senators.
No people that act solely on the will of the people that vote online.
You know the,
the really the,
the only way that I could see it happening is,
is we need more states
rights.
Like someone needs to go whack down the federal government's kind of authority.
The federal government should be responsible only with national security and
they should have way more fucking check points on it than that.
Maybe some national federal crimes that they're pursuing.
Shit like that.
Basically keep us safe,
keep these big major things from happening to everybody.
But other than that,
the states should decide shit.
And you know what would happen?
The states that made cool laws,
laws that make sense,
what fucking get overrun with people and they'd be thriving and their GDP per
state would be kicking ass.
And then other states was stuck in stupid idiots,
you know,
stuck in their old ways.
Running was shit laws and putting people in jail for doing things that are
completely have their own prerogative.
You know,
those states would slowly start to depopulate.
people would be like,
fuck this state.
I'm not going Outta here.
I'm going over to this state,
the state suite.
And that would be at least some level of correction,
some motivation to find a balance that,
you know,
shows actually what people want.
A state could elect a cool leader.
I don't think it's possible for the federal government to elect the Cooley.
I thought Obama was cool.
I thought he was one of them.
I thought he was going to be fucking great,
but he didn't turn out,
you know,
nearly as I'd hoped in that regard.
And I think because of that,
I really feel like that system is fucking rigged.
But a state governor,
you know,
you could get a cool one in state government,
they should come together and make it.
If they really had autonomy to make those laws,
that can make a fucking huge difference.
Yeah,
I agree.
But the real problem is the federal government always wants to take power over
the state government and things,
especially like marijuana.
That's where the big issue is that the state wise,
it's legal in California for medical marijuana,
but federally it's always illegal.
So when these people get arrested,
they go to federal trial and they're not even allowed to use the phrase medical
marijuana because it doesn't exist on a federal level.
There is no such term as medical marijuana,
even though there's,
you know,
thousands of doctors that a spouse,
the use of marijuana for a variety of ailments,
it doesn't matter.
And the federal trial,
this fucking cunt bag,
corrupt government,
you're not even allowed to say it.
Now,
how could that possibly be a government that's looking out for the interest of
the people?
You would prevent someone from using terminology that would accurately explain
their position on the subject just to make it easier for you to win.
And all they could do is say,
are you selling drugs?
You sold drugs.
Thank you.
He sold drugs,
which would be four years in jail.
Whatever the fuck it is.
And that's what these people have to go through.
That's the kind of bullshit these people have to go through.
That is not a government,
that is a bunch of cunts that are running people into the ground and holding
them down with their boots and anybody that has ever done that or or petition
for that to be in position should be removed from society.
They should throw them in a fucking volcano.
You're an asshole period.
You want to lock people up because they're selling medical marijuana and then
when you would been trial,
they can't even say medical marijuana.
Really wheelie.
What kind of piece of shit are you?
What kind of weird black socks wearing scotch drinking cunt bag or you,
you old cryptic fuckhead with your idea that the universe and and logic and law,
that makes sense.
You.
Well,
you're not a good
representative.
You're not a good person.
That should be in power.
You're a cunt bag period.
That's the only type of people that would ever be in that situation or cons.
It would be,
you know,
it's impossible to count even hope for this,
but if you,
I can only imagine taking some of these people and then let's say you assembled
the best shamans from the different traditions and was like,
you got to run the fucking gauntlet now and what?
I've got to show the same show,
same idea,
Douche bags on mushrooms.
It's my show.
I'm trying to pitch it to Fox.
I have a meeting there this Thursday about another show.
Nice.
It seems like a fun show,
but I mean I got a better idea guys.
What do you say?
You guys want to get crazy.
They were the people that came up with who wants to marry a millionaire,
right?
That we think this is the next level.
Shit.
Douche bags.
You could do it legally and uh,
you know,
Peru could be Iowasca Costa Rica would be a bogus,
take these weeks ago.
Give me anything that can be anything.
Yeah.
And need to have solid.
Take the challenge,
you know,
have these people who are so fixed in their beliefs,
take the chance and see what happens when you go 24 hours with truth looks.
That's too deep,
bro.
How about to smoke a joint?
How about just give them a little bit of DMT.
That's only 15 minutes about that.
Let's get baby steps before you leap them into some crazy of boating.
Camping experience.
So did your,
your chicken not enjoy as much as you enjoyed it?
She had a very hard experience,
was way more challenging.
She was struggling with a lot of,
you know,
deeper issues.
Who's very visual.
She had like a,
a physical representation of a,
of a part of herself that was almost like a,
like a demon that she had to slay.
You know,
you ever see that Bruce Lee Movie Dragon?
You know where he has that demon that's kind of,
it was kind of hovering over them,
hovering over him,
and eventually he has to fight it.
Like she lived that through vision and eventually a Bruce Lee movie.
I know he wasn't in it.
It was about Bruce Lee was with,
um,
oh yeah,
some dude,
I don't know.
They'll do different to a jogger.
Yeah.
So anyways,
so she had,
she like lived that experience,
saw this like part of herself that was just this kind of,
you know,
demonic kind of feed part of herself.
And this is just kind of visually visualizations that allow you to manifest,
change the,
she had to take that and like fight it,
bring it out into the lawn,
kill it and bury it,
and then take a sword and like put it.
So it was like this intense fucking,
well,
she woke up on the counselor was dead.
She's gonna fucking kitchen knife.
She thought the counselor was a dragon.
You know,
you're sowing.
Capacitive is insane.
When you're fighting someone with a sword.
Are you sure you know what you're doing?
What was she doing dealing during this [inaudible] it feels like at a certain
point,
the only thing I could say,
you know when you're not,
you're nauseous and you're fucked up and it feels like there's like a 500 pound
pancake on your body,
you almost feel completely immobilized.
Like you can't get up.
Wow.
You know,
you really can't do anything at this point when you're in the kind of the heat
of it.
It's just the buzz around your body and you're just pancake.
I backtracked to do,
I think I distracted you and you never finish.
What happened when you were trying to get a boner?
I abandoned that.
I abandoned that quickly.
I mean,
it was like kind of going through your mind or you tried?
I was blown out,
so I really tried.
That's where I really encountered here.
What's,
what I was going to the bathroom.
No,
I mean it was,
it was Kinda,
it was kinda silly.
I mean,
I just,
at that point,
you know,
your body is under such duress.
Like the penis is like,
I have no fucking business to do here.
You know,
let's,
let's take this blood and mobilize it somewhere else.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing?
The body is like,
I've always said this,
it's weird.
Did the penis is like so volatile,
like the erection,
the erection is so elusive.
I mean,
when you,
when you're in the right mood and everything's cool and you went to a woman and
you make an APP,
boom,
you get an erection,
but you can't get an erection.
Why plane is crashing.
You know,
people are like,
Ooh,
do the bleeding was crazy.
I read pairs right next.
Please stop fucking,
no,
you wouldn't,
man.
No Way.
You're going to get a boner when the plane is crashing.
If you get a boner where the plane is crashing,
you might be the biggest freak on earth fucks.
Fuck Rick James.
He wasn't a super freak.
You're a super freak.
You got a bone or while the fuck while you're riding the plane going down and
you're shooting giant bucket loads everywhere.
I mean,
no,
the,
the is not like a Rhino Horn that's on duty 24 seven.
The boner is a very elusive sort of a,
a chemical reaction that has to take place.
There's a lot of things have to be in line.
Is a lot of switches to have to be going off before a boner happens.
Yeah.
This is the Boga is not one of those switches.
It is the anti switch.
That's what a fucking terrible idea.
You don't think nature knows when you should be breathing when you dick doesn't
work anymore.
It's because you're on your way to dying stupid.
Right.
Okay.
There's a lot of shit going down.
You know,
don't fix that by just shooting out whatever loads you're,
you're dusty machinery can create you loads of cracking.
I'd fucking week old bagels can clue [inaudible] when you're shooting these
dusty loads because you've gotten some sort of an erection because some guy came
with some crazy chemicals.
It gives you a boner when the wind blows,
like whatever.
Riddick I mean our PR,
our priorities are so funny.
I mean I know that they didn't plan on coming out with Viagra for,
for penis enlargement cause it's just something else.
Right.
Or for penis.
A hardening.
I'm sure.
I mean I think it was your,
to have their eye on that forever.
That's the fine.
They knew that was a huge market.
Something else happened and I'm,
I might be wrong cause I know there's a bunch of drugs that happens like,
like broke.
Sure.
Yeah.
Cause Rogaine was rationally.
Or Proskauer was like a prostate enlargement drug and they found it.
It makes people grow hair back.
And that's where they came out with Propecia.
It's like a bunch of different drugs that do things like that.
I thought that was the case with that,
but I'm not sure.
Could be.
Yeah,
it's a funny,
it's a funny situation.
But the,
that whole,
I mean the physical body on it,
Bogut takes a fucking beating and that's just kind of what,
imagine just in a no water and no food for 24 hours.
So fucking terrible.
So we make it through.
It was a pretty crazy night.
I mean,
I didn't unbenounced to me,
I was getting bitten by ants as this was going on too,
which was even worse.